Ready, boom. And we're live.
Hello Lex. Hey, what's going on?
The sequel part too. You have a very
similar, if not the exact same suit on.
This is all I wear. You look very
professional, very reservoir dogs,
reservoir dogs. What it was go to the best
secret of all time. Godfather, part two.
Is that the best of you?
Go over on time.
I think John Wick might be having
quick same. See how dare you sir.
Godfather part two. I mean that's, that
has to be the best sequel. Okay then,
and if this has godfather, part two,
it's definitely not do part three.
Part three was terrible.
Right? Well let's,
let's not offend anyone but it was not
as good. Yeah, I don't remember it.
It was a, the older Pachino. Ah,
would that depot voice that was
like way later, right? Yeah,
that was nineties Oh, okay.
So it's like point break.
The remix. Yes. When they try
to Redo things like way, way,
way later, they almost never,
except the alien franchise.
They've done a pretty fucking
good job with the Alien Fred.
They had a couple of duds in there,
but for the most part I've actually
never seen alien franchise. Who are you?
What are you in a science?
Intelligent men can disagree but
you're not in the science. I Dunno.
I'd prefer prefer Al Pachino.
I would say that, uh,
the older sent a woman an opportunity,
you know that really? Yeah. Watts
come on the, yeah, he got
the Oscar for that one.
What about the one when he played the
devil and the devil? Okay. There's,
there's two. There's duds for everybody.
What was that one? That was advocate.
Uh Huh. There you go. That
was a with counter Reeve.
Kiana release from John Wick or John
Waite. Par threes are the Matrix.
The better movie. Not True. Did
you see this? That happened? Uh,
this high school in North Bergen Jersey.
You put on the alien play a couple of
weeks ago. Garney weaver showed up.
She showed up like a cut just the other
day to like say thanks or whatever.
Tell him maybe to awesome.
Oh,
it looked like crazy and I
was just wondering if they
did this when you were in
high school.
Do you think he might've joined drama?
Like if they did the alien play? Loved
it. One of the watched it. All right.
I'm not getting into drama. Those people
cry too much. There's too much work.
It's a cool suit though. Yeah.
Okay. Let's talk about this.
There's two kinds of movies.
There's fun movies and there's movies
that are like transformational for society
gets sent to a woman.
What? Okay. Let's see.
You kind of say scent of a woman
is transformational for society.
One of the greatest scenes
between a man and a woman on film.
The tango scene. Oh, you're not
married? No, I'm not married.
It's like somewhat talking about French
who can't speak French. I see. Yeah.
It's nonsense. I movie sucked.
I read about French in a book
talking about France without ever
being to Paris. Scent of a woman.
Your favorite movie? No,
it's not my favorite. I think
that movie sucked either.
By the way, if you get mad right now, I
want to barely remember it, but it is,
it is up there.
I'm sure it's a good movie.
That's one of the greatest performances.
But Jesus Christ,
you'll go off to a good start.
Yeah,
I bet you there's thousands of
people agree with me right now. Yeah,
there's millions that don't.
And they're called haters.
Everyone had disagrees is always or,
okay.
So what's your favorite love
scene in a movie? Not like,
like between a man and get
married, Bro. Okay. No,
I'm not fire yourself a gal.
There's a little down.
We're not talking about romantic
comedies and I'm saying they're here. Uh,
Romcoms we're talking about serious
like dramatic moments, right? Okay.
So godfather movie,
great movie.
Does it have to have two guys like
shooting each other or know like, okay,
so if you're seeing central a woman.
Yeah, I'm sure I saw it. Yeah.
But I barely remember it. All right,
well there's these, watch it today.
It'd be like a new movie to me.
Okay. There's this broken man.
We'll alert considering
suicide. Right? It's deep.
So he is tortured by,
you know,
by his involvement in the war,
by being responsible.
They all have this kind of stuff.
He's now mentoring a younger version
of himself, was more character,
more integrity and throw out all of this.
He meets this beautiful young woman.
He's blind for the dance and there's
this beautiful moment where they connect.
I mean, okay, listen Phil, what's
the purpose of film, right.
Entertainment or make us think.
I mean, make us think. Hmm.
You know, you're going to
think if you want to think,
nothing makes you think of
film can engage you. You can,
it can resonate with you or not.
I have a movie that I throw
by people whenever I want
to find out whether or not,
I don't want to listen to anything
they have to say about movies.
The Big Lebowski. Yeah. Yeah. That's one
of the greatest moves a lot that could be,
oh, look at you. Okay.
That could be like, yeah,
that could be like slightly
better than sent a woman. Oh boy.
They had also has one of
the greatest scenes, uh,
between a man and a woman when he is,
uh,
when the fine young ladies painting her
toenails and she's offering them sex for
money. Yeah. That would, that's a, that's
a beautiful moment to these beautiful,
yeah. The comedian, that girl
that used to be a hot mess.
What's her name? Tara Reid.
Yeah. She's still a hot masters.
She got her shit together.
She's been like shark.
The shark NATO series is what she's been,
she's in that.
So I passed the big Lebowski test.
And you failed to sent a woman tests.
I don't remember it.
I got to wrap this conversation.
Legitimately. Don't remember
it. I mean, I'm sure it's great.
I'm sure it's great if you're a wise
man, if you like it, I'm sure it's good.
And you also recognize the godfather
three is kind of sucks. Yeah. Yeah.
But I like the old Pachino reminisce.
Listen, Godfather is about,
uh, your people. The Italian
people have dominated the mob,
the brilliant mob movies, right?
I mean, godfathers about family,
right. There's something
deeply like genuine about that,
that like in our modern
society we really crave for.
So it's like bigger than the individual.
Bigger than the rules of society.
Government, the man. It's family
above all. Right. That, that's like a,
I dunno, that's timeless. That's
the moment with the young Pachino when
he talks to what his brother Fredo says,
don't ever take sides against
the family again, ever. I mean,
that's one of the greatest
moments. That's great moment. It's
all right. All right. All right.
I'm a romanticizing a movies here,
but like John Wick though.
Huh? Never seen it. Whoa.
I've never seen it.
It's a good, excuse me.
It's good movie to watch
on the treadmill is, uh,
is he playing a Russian mobster and that
kills a bunch of them though.
And he speaks Russian and
he works for the Russians.
Kills people for the Russians.
You know,
canneries is one of the greatest
human beings ever. I think so. Yeah.
He's like the nicest guy I heard.
He's a really nice guy,
but he plays a bad gangster. Oh, what
am I going to be a little bit more fit?
Work out a little bit more. I've seen
him without a shirt on, like, hmm.
Not quite buying it, but that's
okay. The average man. Yeah.
But the average man's not the
fucking best assassin of all time
with all this martial arts skill.
Like weight or yeah,
but fate or his big fade or
might have like a gut buddies.
A thick motherfucker.
Okay.
Especially young fade or ever see
young fate or when he was in his prime,
like back when he fought like
Fujita like back when, uh, this,
there's a picture of fate or standing
around with a bunch of kettle bells.
You ever see that picture? Nope.
I was fade. Oregon's lifting days,
I suspect. And this is
coming from, that's,
that's one when fader was fairly
young up there, but that's a,
that's not the one I'm talking about.
You know,
the one with the kettle bells is that
picture up CEB found that picture never a
six pack insight. No, no six pack. But um,
I suspect that fade or might have been
on some performance enhancing substances
during his prime. You mean like hard
training? Lots of drilling technique. Uh,
set of strategy, steroid hot dare
you sir. Dude, he was in pride.
Everybody was on steroids. Yeah. That's
him. Look at him. That's him in his prime.
Hmm. That's a big motherfucker now.
I do not know if he was on anything,
but everybody else was, I
mean, literally everybody,
they had it in their contract that you,
we will not test for steroids.
You know, ensign anyway.
Told me that they like essentially
encouraged people to take steroids. Yeah.
The pride days.
That's right.
It's not like Russians don't have a long
history of using performance enhancing
substances. You, I'm sure you saw that
movie, um, acreages. Did you see it? Yup.
Fascinating. Right. It's, it's a, it's
fascinating. I mean, I, I don't, uh,
steroids often feel to me like
a bit of a witch hunt. Uh,
oftentimes you assume people
are on steroids. I'm a bit of a,
maybe I'm naive or an optimist,
but I tend to give people the benefit
of the doubt until proven otherwise.
But a curious obviously proves that it
was kind of throws a monkey wrench of
those gears.
But you know with a,
with fate or the technique and
that technique to execution,
the timing, the brilliance of his
movement, no doubt that heart, no,
he was phenomenal. I just want to, if
not the greatest heavyweight of all time,
he certainly one of them and I don't think
steroids would help that. Yes, they do.
They help. Yeah. They held that guy
particular, yeah. They help everything.
They help you training, they help your
business, your ability to recover.
They help your explosive power, they help
your speed. They help everything that,
but they also, it's not just
steroids, like a lot of them on EPO,
Epo,
radically in enhances your endurance and
they're starting to catch people need
they just a stripped Tj Dillashaw the
UFC bantamweight champion for start for a
EPO or other, it's tragic. Yes,
it is tragic. Especially Tj,
you mean he's a just a phenomenal fighter.
If not,
I mean certainly top 10 pound for pound
and then this is one of those things
that comes up and you go,
oh man,
it's a legacy killer and this world we
have to kind of reconsider what kind of
a, what should be allowed and not,
yeah, I agree with that. That there,
there is an idea of what you should
make stair was legal or not legal,
sorry, uh, a lot or some kind
of supplementation like, well,
where's the line when you,
when you start to talk about the future
of martial arts, the future sport,
if you can control the levels
so that they're healthy. I mean,
isn't that the reason that they're
not allowed is because if abused,
they become unhealthy. Uh, they damaged
longterm wellbeing of the person. There's,
look,
if that was the case,
we wouldn't allow fighting because
fighting is more damaging and steroids for
sure,
for sure.
Getting punched and kicked and fucking
need in the face and elbowed into
unconsciousness that is way worse
for you than steroids there.
The concern is not for the athlete,
the concerns for the opponent. Um,
the idea is that you will be able to
inflict punishment that you would not
ordinarily be able to inflict.
You will have more endurance,
you will have more power, you will
hurt someone potentially even look,
there's going to be a time where someone
dies in a mixed martial arts of that.
And if that's someone who was the
victor who did not die was on steroids,
it is going to be a huge national tragedy
and a massive disaster for the sport,
for everything. If that ever does
happen, we can only hope it never does.
But for sure, you know,
it's a, it's a very,
very dangerous game you're
playing and when you are,
martial arts is a very dangerous game.
And when you are enhancing your body
with chemicals that are illegal while
you're doing that game,
the real question is though,
here's my take on it and this is w is
it's one of the most human subjects.
And that being meaning, meaning
that it's messy. Humans are messy.
Like there's good and there's bad,
you know,
look like abortion is a messy subject.
It's messy. You know, whether you have,
whether you agree with someone's
right to have it or not, it is.
What you're doing is, especially as
the fetus gets older, it's messy.
You know, when it's a complicated
discussion, it's not a clear,
it's not like you should drink water.
You know what I mean? And it's like,
it's a very complicated
discussion. Steroids are a
very complicated discussion.
You're not allowed to do them,
but they exist for a reason.
The reason why they exist
is they're really effective.
They're really effective
at enhancing your body.
But how much of that will we allow?
We allow Korea team,
we allow supplements in terms
of, you know, there's, uh,
there's certain things that can slightly
elevate your testosterone slightly
elevate your growth hormone.
We allow sauna on ice baths and all
these things that have shown to enhance
recovery. But that's, that's too much.
It's too good there, too effective.
Which,
but it's weird.
It's weird that this thing that we found
that makes you better, you can't use.
Yeah. And so I have to go back a little
bit and disagree with you on something.
So in terms of fighting being dangerous
and that's if we want it to forbid
things that are dangerous for
you would fitbit fighting?
I think the main thing you're
doing can be dangerous, right?
The main thing that we're talking
about, the sport, the combat event,
that can be dangerous because
that is what we watch.
Two people at the height of their skill,
ability,
heart passion, putting their life
at risk. That can be dangerous.
But the supplementation around
it, the way to make it, uh,
to make their training better, more
effective, that can be dangerous.
And I thought that can't be named,
can't be dangerous.
So I thought steroids were considered,
were sort of band because abuses
lead to longterm damage to health.
Now we see steroids as cheating,
but it was banned initially
because it has detrimental effects.
You think that's true? It's not. No,
because there's no real
evidence that it's detrimental.
It's not as detrimental as alcohol when
you allow people to drink, bid even, uh,
a bit even when abused, where the bodies,
like there's, there's not a lot of,
like there's a great documentary on it
called bigger, stronger, faster. And, uh,
it's about my friend Chris Bell.
And when you watch that
documentary and you realize like,
oh well did the real negative consequences
of taking steroids or that it shuts
down your endocrine system so it stops
your body's natural production of
testosterone and growth hormone and
hormones, that's the real problem.
And for young people that can be
very devastating and they can lead to
depression and suicidal thoughts and all,
all sorts of really bad things
when your testosterone shuts down.
But as far as like death boy,
I mean there's,
people are prescribed
pain pills every day,
the week and fighters that are on
injuries, uh, that have been, you know,
that have gotten surgery.
They,
they're prescribed pain pills everyday
of the week and those pain pills kill
people left and right.
And that's just a fact.
People die of those things all the time,
much more so than die of steroids.
So I'm not advocating for the use
of steroids. Right. I'm just, I'm,
I'm being pretty objective
and neutral about this,
but I'm just looking at it like it is
a, it's a very messy subject. Yeah.
It's very eloquently put.
But so,
so your problem in terms of damaging the
opponent is if one side takes terrorism.
Exactly what happens if both, the problem
is you would require someone do that,
that maybe someone's a holistic person.
They don't want it introduce any unnatural
exogenous steroids into their body
and hormones in their body.
They want,
they want everything to be produced
by the human body. They want to,
they want to eat healthy food,
train hard,
sleep well and compete naturally had
CT Fletcher here yesterday, right? Yes.
Is Natural Bodybuilder. Yes. Not
Body build powerlifter outlet. Yeah,
but that's not required. Right. This
is, you're not requiring people,
you're giving them the choice.
So you know,
it's an interesting possibility where
in moderation you'll be able to allow
steroids and future of athletics because
with an argument that if I had done a
moderation, you can actually create
healthier athletes. Yeah. That's,
I mean that's a real argument for the
Tour de France, the Tour de France,
they say that you actually are better
off and healthier taking steroids. Yeah.
And Epo.
Then you are doing it without it.
Cause it's so unbelievable that you're
ruling on the body. I mean those athletes,
I basically,
some of the best people in the world
at suffering long term suffering,
it's incredible. Ultra marathon
runners, all those guys,
it's incredibly different sort of thing.
You know.
And you know the thing about
ultra marathon runners,
there's didn't even test them
cause they're like, good luck.
Those people have iron.
Will's like,
I don't know if it like Courtney dual
Walters, a woman who, you know, she is,
she's been in here,
she eats candy,
just drinks beer each candy
and pizza make sense? Yeah.
I mean she's just got fucking iron will
or her will is indomitable and you could
take all the steroids you want
when you're running for three days.
That chick is going to beat you.
He just doesn't know how to quit.
Just has no quit in.
Did you see the podcast with her
where she talked about how she fell?
She couldn't see. She was
in experiencing, uh, I think
it was inner ocular
hemorrhaging. Yeah. So her,
her eyeballs were bleeding internally,
something like that where it was
impeding her vision. She couldn't say,
I would stop. I would stop running.
No, she fell because you couldn't see,
busted her head open, bleeding all down.
Her face keeps running. Barely, barely.
Can see her feet as she's running,
keeps running.
I'm glad those people
are out there like that.
Like I don't know how to
quit. Really? Yeah. I'm like,
I do a lot of stuff like
that. Like stupid. Like I ran
yesterday. I couldn't sleep.
I ran here yesterday, 13 miles. I'm not a
runner. Just, just this weird obsession.
Do you don't run. I run, but I'm not
a runner. I look at my body. I'm a,
I have a similar body like yours.
We're not exactly,
we'd do like better built for short
sprinting and then maybe killing somebody
with our hands
versus a long distance.
You're a black belt in Jujitsu, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Where do you train it now?
Train at Broadway. Jiu in
Boston. Nice. And that's, uh,
and before I was in, in Philly, balanced
studios with film and movies and so on.
Uh, but Cobb Bochniac I actually
transcend Broadway. Oh really?
I love that car. Yeah, he a
I had last time was on it.
I actually wanted to talk about this,
a bead fight cause I'm,
I'm rushing so I loved the Russian
way. But I also love the, I mean Kyle,
Timmy represents like the American,
he's like the rocky, if you,
if you remember that fight with the,
against the deep,
the third round he was winning. I mean
that's the best of what martial arts is.
MMA is to me is like you
have two technicians,
they just throw everything
away. Like screw this, I'm
just going to throw it out.
Was it beat?
Had broken his hand broke his hand
somewhere I think in the second round.
So he was pretty compromised
going into the third round.
I couldn't really fire back and
Kyle was just has zero Quintin them.
The guy's an animal. Yeah. I
mean that's the most beautiful,
you talk about like technical fights
in the ground or technical striking.
Like when like two technicians throw
everything away. That's, I'm sorry.
But that's what is the,
uh,
that I'd get a love the most about any
kind of fighting, any kind of sport.
I enjoy it in the moment.
I discourage it heavily.
I don't think it's a smart way
to fight. Yeah, well that's,
that's probably your job is my job.
It's like what I like, like I get,
I get the impulse, but I don't want
people to give into the impulse.
I think fighting is something
that you should do correctly.
You should do, you should do, there's,
there's principles that you
should follow to fight correctly.
It doesn't mean that you shouldn't
take chances, but you know,
there's moments like, um, um,
Ricardo Lamas when,
uh,
he fought Max Holloway and they just
stood in the center of the ring for the
last few seconds of the fight and Max
Holloway pointed down at the ground and
he's like, come on right here, right here.
And they just started so wing in Heymach.
It was amazing. Well, it happened,
but if I was in Max's corner,
I'd be like, don't, no,
don't do that, man. This macho shit is
going to give you fucking brain damage.
You're going to get hit with shots he
wouldn't get hit with. That's a difficult,
like you said, human nature is messy.
I would say that is the greatest.
That is the greatest moment of
their lives. What? That war?
No,
listen,
this is the greatest moment
of Max Holloway's like Max
Holloway is the greatest
featherweight all time discussion.
No,
but Max Holloway is the greatest
featherweight of all time.
He's the guy who destroyed José
Aldo twice. He's a guy that he's,
he's beaten everybody in
front of him at featherweight.
The idea that this one moment where they
decided to throw out all his skill and
technique and just swing for the
bleachers in the middle of the octagon.
It was a fun moment.
It was great to watch,
but the idea that that was the
greatest moment of his life, his word.
You're a crazy person. Yeah. There's
moments in sports. They're just magic.
Olympics. Bring that when like the thing
that you don't think should happen,
it can't possibly happen or is not wise
where people just throw everything away.
Yeah. Yeah. A passion person.
Fashion Person. Yeah, for sure.
That's an interesting thing for someone
who studies artificial intelligence.
I mean if anybody listened to his podcast,
but what the fuck does this guy do?
Our dogs.
They talk about movies.
So many people talk about
Sean was vehicle. We are,
we have plenty of time sir.
We have plenty of time.
But that's the beautiful thing about
this podcast. We're just talking.
So tell me what you got
here with your notes man.
I mean you are fucking prepared. I
mean, yeah, a lot of shit here. Many,
many pages for sure. I don't want to miss,
I don't miss stuff. I mean there's a,
there's been a lot of exciting stuff on
the autonomous vehicle space since you
came on.
I got a Tesla and I've experienced what
that thing is like when I put it on
autopilot and it's stunning.
It's crazy.
I mean this is in terms of the
performance of the v amazing well in,
in terms of its ability to change lanes
and its ability to drive without you
doing anything.
I just put my hand on the wheel and
hold it there and it does all the work.
So because like one or two
people listened to this podcast,
I want to take this opportunity and
tell people, if you drive a Tesla,
whether you listen to this now or a
year from now, two years from now,
Tesla or any other car,
keep your damn eyes on the road.
So whatever you think
the system is able to do,
you will have to still monitor the road
and you still have to take over when it
fails, if, when really.
So
we're throwing,
this is like the moment where
throwing down right now.
I think it's an express your
level of expertise obviously.
I mean I'm not throwing down with you
on, no, I think it's really important
to, in this transitionary phase,
whatever the car company, uh,
whatever the system that we
don't overtrust the system,
we don't become complacent. We don't
think he could do more than he can.
Currently. 40,000 people die in the
United States from, from fatal crashes.
The number one reason for that is
distraction. So texting, smartphones,
how much has it gone up since smartphones,
people don't exactly where
they're trying to understand that.
There's a lot of studies showing
that it's significant increases,
but it's hard to say it's because of
smartphones, but it's almost obvious.
I mean it's pretty obvious.
The flip side is even though everybody's
not using a smart phone, texting,
so on, they've become better
at using the smartphone.
So they're better at texting and driving.
The better balancing that.
Now this is a horrible thing to do.
So if you're listening to this podcast,
you should listen to it in your car and
keep your eyes on the road and not text.
I think worst was Pokemon when Pokemon
was in its prime.
I was watching a guy on the highway
playing Pokemon as he was driving and uh,
no more than one person. Two
people, a guy. And I saw a girl,
dude wants to holding the phone on
the steering wheel. Playing Pokemon.
Yeah. Yeah. It's incredible.
What are you doing Jeremy?
That's GRANDPA's. Oh Shit. Sorry.
I'm confused. What does this,
uh, this grandpa in Japan,
he drives around on a bike.
Oh, playing Pokemon. All, it's
the same exact time. This guys,
15 phones. It's ridiculous.
This guy needs to find hookers.
There's people that do this also in
their car with maybe four or five doing
exactly what you're saying. This man needs
a better hobby. This is preposterous.
Look at the,
look at his file.
He can't see what the fuck's
going on in front of him.
He spends about $300 a month to
buy virtual currencies in the game.
Wow. That guy's board or in
an innovative genius thing.
In that perspective,
when people misuse their
innovative Josie innovative,
he's just playing a stupid game while
he's driving around on his bike like an
asshole. Well, he's doing is
back to the set of a woman thing.
It's passion.
It's the most amazing moment of his life.
I'm sure most people are on my side
scent of a woman versus you think most
people are on your side.
They think Santam a woman is the
greatest movie of all that to a woman,
but I was defending GFE
father sent him a woman.
You weren't defending
godfather against me. I mean,
I'm going to throw you under the plan.
Okay.
I'm going to manipulate this conversation.
Jamie, can you edit this in post?
Did you see the video that
just came out yesterday of a,
a Tesla on autopilot avoiding
a crash. All right, so yeah,
I have and there's a lot of example.
Quite a few of those.
Yeah,
of course.
It's like hard to prove exactly what
happened and where the auto Paul was
involved.
Just like on the flip side,
it's hard to prove that autopilot
was involved in the dangerous stuff,
but think by any measure the media
is really negative in terms of their
reporting on Tessa there I think,
I think you've talked to
this about before in general,
negativity gets more clicks and I
think Tesla negative stuff on Tesla,
it gets a lot of clicks so
and well not Tesla. Let,
let me speak more broadly about autonomous
vehicles. If there's any fatality,
any crash, it's overrepresented,
it's over reported on.
So I need to meet people
who are interested in AI
helping save lives in these
systems like autopilot.
I feel you carry the responsibility of
being at least as good of a driver you
are when it's under manual control.
So don't text and drive.
Keep your eyes on the road by saying
anything over and over in this podcast is
that drunk driving of course is the
other one. And so don't drink and drive,
but the number one thing is distracted
driving. So put your phone down. I agree.
Um, listen to some music, some
classic Rock Classic Rajoy. Yeah,
yeah. Click credence into a no, no, no.
Like it. Like you would
change the channel. Now you're
going to put me in this,
of course. The side.
There you go. I take a,
I take my shirt off.
No.
Uh,
Glen Lynyrd Skinner course,
Hendrix course called jerks.
And I have to admit something. I thought
about messaging you a couple of times.
Uh, I wanted to, I play
guitar. Do you? Yeah,
you can't,
are you good at Jujitsu? Yeah, I'm good.
Okay. I'm on black belt. I'm pretty good.
You're a black belt too. I'm sure you're
good. Yeah. I'm not world class and A,
I'm on use. Fuck me up. I'm a three
striped purple belt guitar. Ah,
that's a good way of putting it. Yeah.
Yeah. I say that. What about hunting?
I'm like a blue belt hunting.
Yeah. Yeah, yeah.
I've been doing it like I got the purple
belt by doing it a long time as opposed
to being amazing. But you take lessons
now. I learned everything myself.
I have a couple of videos online.
Me playing comfortably numb.
Learn from watching videos or did you
learn from books? Like how did you like,
let me see this.
Give me this.
Look at you.
It's going to get us food off of Youtube.
Yeah, this is going to play. No, no, no.
It probably won't pick it up and if it
picks it up it'll be to my channel and
I'll shot. It's me playing.
What do you mean it's so good.
It sounds like people from
humming songs for you.
But so this is on youtube and this
is the, no, I didn't know that.
But this didn't get blocked.
If you were humming a song and then
someone made a claim on that song,
it would block our,
our youtube like literally we could
get demonetized and put we could,
we lose our streaming and bill. Lots
of things can happen. Lots of things.
It's fucked up man.
Like we've,
we've gotten flagged for
watching something on the screen,
picture in picture,
no sound commenting on it,
and we get flagged and they want all the
advertising revenue from a three hour
show for five, 10 seconds of a video.
It's a slightly broken system. Ooh,
it's broken. But there's a lot of scam
artists too. So I, I played another song,
black Betty. Oh yeah. And
I got, I don't know. Yeah,
I played the damn song. But they,
they said it was, it wasn't,
they did exactly that.
Oh,
they said it was the ram jam or whatever
it said it was there and I may have
borrowed beat behind it from them. I'm
not sure. I just took all the like,
yeah. Well that's what I was
thinking about that song.
Like it sounded like there was other
shit going on besides just your guitar.
Oh No, that's all me real. It's all
made bad. The back we had that again.
That's really good, man. He sounded good.
That's a great fucking song
to comfortably numb. You know,
the scariest thing for me to
play guitar on this podcast.
So I was like going back and forth. Oh
really? I do it. Should I not do it?
Actually play, play, play. And the only,
it was only a few people that
ever played play Everlast um,
Ben and Suzanne from honey, honey. Uh,
Gary Clark didn't write and he just came
on and talked and he brought his guitar.
I wanted to play a Hendrix here.
Really live life.
You got it right with you right
now in the torture? Yeah. Well, no,
I meant I was okay.
Sure. If in the future,
and I'm not promising I scare you
were a Hendrix wig with a Bandana.
Is that racially insensitive though?
You're allowed to Joe.
I will not take it. As I said face. You're
allowed. Okay. The hair is like, just,
you know, it's just hair. Is this how
you can't wear dreadlocks? So, yeah.
So there's rules, but I think you, yeah,
there's rules. I just, Hendricks is
above all the rules though, right? Well,
he's the goat of guitar players.
That's the goat. One of them.
You know the reason why this
call, the show's called, yeah,
I stole it from Jimmy
Hendrix. Yeah. What's mine.
I don't remember if we
brought this up last time,
but I just remember seeing this video
where you're playing guitar while you were
driving. Yup. Well you shouldn't do that,
dude. It's the reason why he was doing it.
Why are you doing that on a test
track? Oh, what kind of car is that?
Looks at the Lincoln Lincoln Mkc. Yes sir.
Oh, they do that? The Lincolns do that.
We converted it and we,
that's The r code controlling the car.
Wow.
That is crazy.
So you converted this car to drive
autonomous Thomas? They, yeah. Wow.
And what,
what exactly do you have
to do to a car to change?
Like, because that car
does not have the capacity,
the capacity to do anything like that.
So the right my correct.
No, no, no, no, absolutely not. But
you are absolutely correct. The,
there's the first part is being able
to control the car with a computer,
which is converting it
to be drive by wire so you can control
the steering and the braking acceleration
to, to basically be able
to control with a joystick.
And then you have to put laser sensors
all around the cars that we need to kind
of sensor and a software.
So what's the best kind of sensor?
Is it the cold laser? A lot of
debate on this. And this is the big,
this is the throwdown between
Elon Musk and everybody else. Oh,
they all Musk says the best sensors,
camera everybody else while everybody
else says that at this time,
Lidar,
which are these lasers is the best sensor.
So that I'm more on the side in
this case on camera and Elan Musk.
So here's the difference. Lasers are
more precise. They worked better in,
in poor lighting conditions.
They're more reliable.
You can actually build safe
systems today that use lidar.
The problem is that they don't have,
they're much information.
So we use our eyes to drive and
uh, cameras, the same thing.
And they have just a lot more information.
So if you're going to build
artificial intelligence systems,
so machine learning systems that learn
from huge amounts of data cameras,
the way to go because you can learn so
much more. You can see so much more.
So the, the richer,
deeper censor his camera,
but it's much harder.
You have to collect a huge amount of data.
It's a little bit more futuristic.
So it's longer term solution.
So today to build a safe vehicle,
you have to go lidar tomorrow,
however you define tomorrow, he almost
says it's an a year. Others say it's five,
10, 20 years cameras the way to go. So
that's, that's the, the hard debate.
And there's, there's a lot of other
debates, but that's one of the core ones.
It's basically for camera, you, if you
go camera, like you're doing the Tusla,
there's seven cameras in your
Tesla, uh, three looking forward,
there's all around, so on
one looking inside, no, you
have the model s yeah, yeah.
So that, that one doesn't have a camera
that's looking inside. So it's all,
all cameras plus radar
and ultrasonic sensors.
That approach requires collecting huge
amounts of data. And they're doing that.
They drove now about 1.3
billion miles under autopilot.
She uses, yeah, it's, it's a,
it's a very large amount of data.
So you're talking about over
500,000 vehicles have autopilot,
450 I think thousand have the new version
of autopilot autopilot to which is the
one you're driving and all of
that is data. So all of those,
all the edge cases,
what they call them,
all the difficult situations that occur
is feeding the machine learning system
to become better and better and better.
And the open question is how much better
does need to get to get to the human
level performance?
And like one of the big thing,
one of the big assumption,
so a Cema beings is that we think that
driving is actually pretty easy and we
think that humans suck at driving
those two assumptions.
Do you think like driving it,
you know you stay in the lane,
you stop at the stop sign is
pretty easy to to automate.
And then the other one is you think
like humans are terrible drivers and so
there'll be easy to build a machine
that outperforms humans are driving now.
There is,
that's a,
I think there's a lot of flaws behind
that intuition we take for granted how
hard it is to look at the scene.
Like everything you just did picked up,
moved around some objects.
It's really difficult to build
an artificial intelligence
system that does that.
To be able to perceive and understand
the seen enough to understand the physics
of the scene. Like all these objects
that it like how to pick them up,
the texture of those objects,
the weight to understand glasses
folded and unfolded, open water bottle,
all those things is common sense
knowledge that we take for granted.
We think it's trivial but there is no
artificial system in the world today.
Nor will there be for perhaps quite a
while that can reason do that kind of
common sense. Reasoning about the
physical world. Add to that, uh,
pedestrians.
So add some crazy people in this room
right now to the whole scene and being
able to notice like, or this guy is
an asshole look and what was he doing?
What does he know? And get off that
skateboard out. Jesus isn't traffic yet.
And the considering, not that he's an
asshole, he's a respectable skateboarder.
It that in order to make
him behave a certain way,
you yourself have to behave a certain way.
So it's not just you have
to perceive the world,
you have to act in a way that you have
to assert your presence in this world.
You have to take risks.
So in order to make the skateboard
and not cross the street,
you have to have accelerate if you have
the right away. And these are that,
there's a game theoretic
game of chicken to get right.
I mean we don't even know how
to approach that as a, as uh,
artificial intelligence sort of research
community and also as a society do we
want an autonomous vehicle that speeds
up in order to make a pedestrian not
cross the street,
which is what we do all the time.
We have to assert our presence.
If there's a,
if there's a person who doesn't have the
right of way, it could begins crossing.
We're going to either maintain speed or
speed up potentially if we want them to
not cross. So that, that
game there to get that right.
That's a dangerous game for a robot.
It's for a robot.
And for us to be rationally,
if that God forbid,
least of fatality for us as a society
to rationally reason about that.
I think about that.
I mean a fatality like that could
basically bankrupt the company.
There's a lawsuit going on
right now, um, about uh, uh,
an accident in northern
California with the Tesla. Yeah.
And Are you aware of,
well yeah, that one. Yeah,
this was the circumstances about that one.
So there was a,
I believe in mountain view,
a fatality and a Tesla where it,
this is a common problem for all,
all link keeping systems. Like,
like that's a lot of pilot is a,
those,
a divider in the highway and basically
the car was driving, you know,
along the lane and then the car in
front moved to an adjacent lane and this
divider appeared right?
So you have to now steer to the right
and the car didn't in one straight into
the divider. Oh Wow.
And it's, you know, uh,
the basically what that boils down to
is the car drifted out of lane, right?
Or it didn't adjust properly to the
lane and those kinds of things happen.
And this is because the person was
allowing the autopilot to do everything.
Nope. That you can't. So we have
to be extremely careful here.
I don't know that the really
deep details of the case,
I'm not sure exactly
how many people will do.
So there's a judgment on what the person
was doing and then there's an analysis
of what the system did,
right. The system did,
it drifted out of lane and the
question is did the person,
was the person paying attention and was
there enough time given for the person
to take over and if they were paying
attention to catch the vehicle,
steer back onto the road.
As far as I believe the only information
they have is hands on steering wheel.
And they were saying that like half.
That's half the minute
leading up to the crash.
The hands weren't on the steering
wheel or something like that.
Basically trying to infer where
the person paying attention or not,
but we don't have the information exactly
what wa where were their eyes? Right.
You can only make guesses
as far as I know. Again,
so the question is,
this is the eyes on the road thing
because I think I've heard Jenna pocket
saying you're attempted to sort of look
off the road that your new Tesla or at
least become a little bit complacent.
The worry,
the worry is that you,
you just rely on the thing
that you would relax too much,
but what would that relaxation lead to
that the problem is if something happened,
if you weren't,
you know when you're driving.
I mean we've discussed this many times
on the podcast to the reason why people
have road rage.
One of the reasons is cause you were
in a heightened state because cars are
flying around you and your
brain is prepared to make
split second decisions and
moves.
And the worry is that you would relax
that because you're so comfortable with
that thing driving everybody that I know
that it's tried that they say you get
really used to it doing that.
You get really used to it
just driving around for you.
So the question is what be, what
happens when you get used to it? Yeah.
You started looking off road.
Do you started texting more?
Do you start watching a movie?
It's that, uh, that, that's a,
that's a really an open question.
And the like for example,
we just did the study,
uh,
published a study from the MIT
on what people in our Dataset,
we have local at this Dataset
of 300 miles and Tesla's,
we instrumented all these Teslas and
watch what people are actually doing and
are they paying attention when
they disengage the system?
So there's a really important moment here.
We have 18,000 of those when
the person catches the car,
you know the disengage
autopilot and that's a really
a Tesla uses this moment as
well. That's a really important
window into difficult cases.
So some percentage of those,
some small percentage,
about 10% is we call them.
Tricky situations is situations where
you have to immediately respond like
drifting out of lane if there's a stopped
car in front. So on. The question is,
are people paying attention
during those moments?
So in our dataset that
we're paying attention,
there were still remaining vigilant.
Now in our Dataset,
the autopilot was going on quote,
encountering tricky
situations every 9.2 miles.
So you could say it was a
failing every 9.2 miles.
That is one of the reasons we believe
that people are still paying it,
remaining vigilant,
that it's regularly and unpredictably
sort of drifting out of the lane or
misbehaving. So you don't overtrust
it, you don't become too complacent.
The open question is when it becomes
better and better and better and better,
will you start becoming complacent when
it drives on the highway for an hour,
an hour and a half and is opposed
to 9.2 miles, make that 50 miles,
60 miles. Do you start to overtrust
it? And that's a really open question.
Do you think or do you anticipate a time
and anywhere in the near future where
you won't have to correct,
you will allow the car to do it
because the car will be perfect.
The car, first of all, we'll never be
perfect. No car will ever be perfect.
Autonomous Vehicles will always,
you think require at least some
sort of manual override. Yeah.
Really. That's interesting that you're
saying that because you work in AI.
Like what makes you think that
that's impossible to achieve?
Well let's, let's talk cause cause
you're using the word perfection.
I think perfection. That's a bad word.
Yeah. So I guess you're implying it.
Let me see. Will it achieve? Because
people are obviously not perfect yet.
We'll achieve a state of competence
that exceeds the human beings.
Okay.
And let's put it in a dark way.
Competence measured by
fatal crashes. Yes. Uh, yes.
I absolutely believe so. And
perhaps in the near term, near term,
five years for me,
five 10 years is near term for Elan,
Elan Musk time that converted to one year.
Have you met him? Yes.
Interviewed him recently.
Fascinating cat, right? Yup.
Got a lot of weird shit bouncing
around behind those eyeballs.
You don't realize until you talked
to him in person, you're like, oh,
got a lot going on
in there, man. Yeah. There's
this passion, this drive. I mean,
it's one of the hurricane of
ideas and a focus and confidence.
I mean, the thing is in a
lot of the things he does,
which I admire greatly from
any man or a woman innovator,
it's just boldly,
fearlessly pursuing new ideas or jumping
off the cliff and learning to fly in
the way down that that's, I mean,
well, no matter what happens,
he'll be remembered as the
great innovators of our
time. Uh, whatever you say,
maybe in my book, Steve Jobs was
as well. Even if you criticize,
perhaps he hasn't contributed
significantly to the
technological development of
the company or the
different ideas they did.
Still his brilliance was in
all the products of iPhone,
of the personal computer, the Mac and so
on. And I think the same is true with uh,
with uh,
with Ilan and yes,
there's in this space of
autonomous vehicles of,
of semi autonomous vehicles,
of driver assistance systems,
it's a pretty tense space to operate in.
There's several communities in there
that are very responsible but also
aggressive in their criticism.
So in driving in the automotive sector,
obviously since Henry Ford and before
there's been a culture of safety of just
great engineering.
These are like some of the best engineers
in the world in terms of large scale
production. He talked about [inaudible]
are you talking about for GM?
These people know how to do
safety well and so care combs, he,
along with silicon valley ideals that
throws a lot of it out the window and says
we're going to revolutionize the
way we do automation in general.
We'll go into make software
updates to the car once a week,
twice a week over the air.
Just like that.
That makes people in the safety engineers
and human factors engineers really
uncomfortable.
Like,
what do you mean you're going to keep
updating the software of the car without
like how are you testing it? Right?
That makes people really uncomfortable.
Why does it make them uncomfortable?
Because the way in the automotive sector,
you test the system, you come up with
a design of the car, every component,
and then you go through like really
rigorous testing before it ever hits the
road.
Right?
Here's an idea from the Tesla
side is where they basically,
they in shadow moe test the software,
but then they just release it.
So essentially the drivers become the
testing and then they regularly update it
to, uh, to, uh, to adjust a,
if any issues arise that makes people
uncomfortable because there's not a
standardized testing procedure.
There's not,
there's not at least the feeling in the
industry of rigor because the reality is
we don't know how to test software in
the same corner of with the same kind of
rigor that we've tasted,
the automotive system tested
automotive system in the past.
So I think it's extremely exciting
and powerful to make software sort of
approach,
uh,
automotive engineering with at least in
part a software engineering perspective.
So just doing what's made
silicon valley successful.
So updating regularly, aggressively
innovating on the software side.
So your Tesla over the air while we're
sitting here could get a total annual
update. The flip of a, uh,
of a bit as a Elon Musk says,
uh, it can be, he can
gain all new capabilities.
That's really exciting, but that's
also dangerous and that, that balance,
we, uh, what's dangerous about it?
That'd be faulty software faulty a bug.
So if you're, you're the
apps on your phone, you know,
fail all the time.
Where as a society used to software
failing and we just kind of reboot the
device when we start the APP.
A the most complex software systems in,
in the world today.
If we think outside of
nuclear engineering and so on,
they're really nobody that they're too
complex to really thoroughly tests.
So a thorough,
complete testing proving that the
software is safe is nearly impossible.
I'm most software systems that that's IX,
that's a,
that's nerve wracking too.
A lot of people because a,
there's no way to prove that the new
software update is safe. So what it,
what is the process like do know
like how they create software,
they update it and then
they tested on something.
How much testing do they do and what,
how much did they do before they
upload it to your car? Yeah,
so I don't have any inside information,
but I have a lot of sort of public
available information, which is, uh,
they, uh, they test the
software in shadow mode,
meaning they see how the new software
compares to the current software by
running it in parallel on the cars and
seeing if there's disagreements, if like,
uh,
seeing if there's any major disagreements
and bringing those up and seeing what
by parallel, I'm sorry. Do you mean
both programs running at the same time?
One, the original update?
Yes. At the same time,
the original update actually controlling
the car and the new update is just
making the same decision, making the
same decisions without them being,
without actually
affecting the actual okay.
Without actually affecting the
vehicles dynamics. And so that's,
that's a really powerful way of testing.
I think the software infrastructure
that Tesla's built a loss for that and I
think other companies should do the same.
That's a really exciting,
powerful way to approach
not just a automation,
not just the autonomous vehicles
or semi autonomous vehicles,
but just safety is basically
all the data that's on cars.
Bring it back to a central point to
where you can use the edge cases,
all the weird situations, and driving to
a, improve the system to test the system,
to learn to understand
where the cars used misused,
how can be improved and so on.
That's an extremely powerful how many
people they have that are analyzing all
this data. It's a, it's a really
good question. So they have,
the interesting thing about driving
is most of it is pretty boring.
Nothing interesting happens.
So they have automated ways of extracting
again what are called edge cases.
So these weird moments of driving and
once you have these weird moments,
they have people annotate it.
I don't know what the number is,
but a lot of companies are doing this.
It's in the hundreds and the thousands
and basically have humans annotate the
data to see what happened.
But most of what they're trying to
do is to automate that annotation.
So to figure out how the da Da da,
it can be automatically used to
improve the system. So they, they have,
they have methods for that because
it's a huge amount of data. Right.
I think in the recent autonomy day,
a couple of weeks ago,
they had this big autonomy day
where they had demonstrated, uh,
the vehicle driving itself on a
particular stretch of road. They,
uh, they showed off that, you know,
they're able to query the data,
basically ask questions
of the data saying, uh,
the example they gave is there's a bike
on the back of a car and a bicycle on
the back of a car. And
they're able to say, well,
when the bicycles in the back of a car,
that's not a bicycle,
that's just the part of the car.
And they're able to now look back into
the data and find all the other cases,
the thousands of cases that happened
all over the world in Europe, in Asia,
in South America and
North America and so on,
and pull all those elements
and then train the train, uh,
the perception system of
autopilot to be able to, to, uh,
better recognize those
bicycles as part of the car.
And so every edge case like that,
they go through saying, okay,
the car freaked out in this moment.
And then we find moments like this in
the rest of the data and then improve the
system. So it's, it's, uh,
this kind of cycle is
the way to deal with, uh,
with problems with failures of the system
is to say every time the car fails at
something, say, is this part
of a bigger set of problems?
Can I find all those problems and
can I improve it with a new update?
And that it just keeps going.
The open question is how many loops like
that you have to take for the car to
become really good, better
than human. Basically,
how hard is driving?
How many weird situations when you
manually drive do you deal with every day
somebody, uh, somebody mentioned,
I don't know that there's like
millions of cases when you watch video,
you see them, somebody you mentioned, um,
that drive a truck or ups truck and
passed cow pastures and they know that if
there's no cows in the cow pasture,
that means they're grazing.
And if they're grazing, I mean like be
using the correct terms. I apologize.
And not a car guy. Uh, that,
that means that there may be
cows up ahead on the road.
There's just this kind of reasoning
it can use to anticipate difficult
situations.
And we do,
we do that kind of reasoning about like
everything cars today can't do that kind
of reasoning. They're just
perceiving what's in front of them.
Now,
outside of Tesla,
how many other companies have autonomous
systems that are driving their cars?
So maybe it's good to step back.
There are several,
and there are several leaders
in each different approach.
So first let's draw a line between the
different types of systems that are one.
There is fully autonomous vehicles.
These are cars you can think about that
don't have a steering wheel or if they
have a steering wheel, it doesn't
matter. They're in full control.
And if there's a crash,
the car companies liable that those exist.
No, it, it's,
it's a gray area though because many
companies are basically saying that that's
what they're doing,
but they're not quite there.
So the leader in that space is a used
to be called Google self driving car
program now it's called Waymo.
They are doing that there.
It's called level four, level
five. There's levels to this game.
And this is this particular level
where it's fully autonomous.
Now they're trying to
achieve full autonomy,
but the way they're doing it currently
is they're testing on public roads with
what's called the safety driver.
So there's a driver always ready to take
over and the driver does have to take
over at some rate, you know, frequently.
And so the fact that the
driver has to take over,
that's not fully autonomous then.
Right?
So there's no car today that you can
just get in without a safety driver.
So there's nobody behind the wheel.
And a using your apps sort of
get from point a to point B,
but out of the cars that are semi
autonomous where there is an autonomous
program,
but you do have to keep your hands on the
wheel and p pay attention to the road.
What, what are the leaders besides Tesla?
There's Tesla and who else is doing it?
So there's,
Yep.
Uh,
there's several systems.
It depends how you define
leader. But so are the, yes.
See this, like does Mercedes and BMW,
they use the same system? Do they,
does someone make a system for cars
or do they create their own systems?
That's a really good question.
So there's, in some cases there
belie and Invidia there's these
companies that Nvidia, the,
the video card be in a car
company. Yup. The same,
the same folks that power
the quake game, right. The,
the graphics and the quake game.
You can use those Gpu graphics
processing to run machine learning code.
So they're also creating the nvidia drive.
Yep.
Scalable Ai Platform for
autonomous driving. In fact, uh,
I don't, when did you buy a Tesla?
Five months ago or something,
something like that.
So the thing in there now,
most likely is a nvidia
draft px two system.
So the one that works on cameras that,
uh,
that just runs code that
takes in camera data,
but it can work on anything else.
So it could work on lidar as well.
Somebody had a system. Yeah.
But it needs a different code.
So the lidar requires very
different kinds of processing.
Does anybody use that with cars? With
all semi autonomous cars? Lighter, yes.
The as well.
Okay.
So semiautonomous we have
to be careful because a,
the Waymo cars like the,
the quote unquote fully autonomous cars
are currently semi autonomous. Okay.
So that's the highest level
of semiautonomous autonomous,
right? Yeah. That guests,
it's, it's not even a highest
level. It's a principle.
It's a philosophy difference.
Cause they're saying we're
going to do full autonomy.
We just not quite there yet.
Uh, most other companies,
they're doing semiautonomous better called
driver assistance systems is they're
saying we're not interested
in full autonomy.
We just want a driver assistance system.
They just helps you steer the car.
So let, let's call those semi autonomous
vehicles or driver assistance systems.
The,
there's several leaders in that space.
Like one car we're studying that's really
interesting is a Cadillac super cruise
system.
So GM has the system,
it's called super cruise that I think is
the best comparable system to autopilot
today. The, uh,
the key differentiator there is,
there's a lot of little elements,
but the key differentiators,
there's a driver monitoring system.
So there's a camera that looks at you
and tells you if your eyes on the road or
not. And if your eyes go off the road
for I believe more than six seconds,
it starts warning you
and says you have to be,
you have to get your eyes back on the
road. So that's called driver monitoring.
That's one of the big disagreements.
For example,
if you mean Ilan and uh,
many experts in the field and Ilan and
the Tesla approach is that there should
be a driver monitoring system.
There should be a camera.
Loquat is Ilan feel like there
shouldn't be, I think his focus,
the Tesla's focus is on just improving
the system so fast and so effectively
that it doesn't matter what the
driver does that it, it, you know,
so essentially no safety net,
no safety net.
And I think they operate like that and
in many ideas that they work with is they
sort of bold leap,
proceed forward to try to make
the car extremely safe. Now,
the concern there is you
have to acknowledge the
psychology of human beings.
Then unless the car
is perfect or under our definition,
perfect,
which is much better than human beings,
then you have to be able to,
you have to be able to make sure that
the people are still paying attention to
help the car out when it fails and for
that you have to have drive a modern,
you have to know what
the car is right now.
Your Tesla only knows about your presence
be from the steering wheel touching
the steering wheel, which is a
kind of driver monitoring system.
It knows you're there, but it's not
nearly as effective at knowing your,
they're cognitively, visually,
you can be tricked by clamps,
seen people do that.
Then develop these clamps that you
just put on the steering wheel.
It'll hold a phone and then also trick
the system into thinking that you're
holding onto the wheel.
Yeah,
you can do a lot of purses actually work
really law are asking me how hanging
purse, no, like shoving
a person and to the,
somebody did that with an
orange or something like that,
but they said it didn't work.
Maybe it needs to be all the
way around the outside of it.
I think it depends on the shape
of that orange, how ripe it is.
This is a lot of debate and no, I, the
point is there's wasted trick the system,
there's a, it's not monitoring the
driver. That's the point, right?
It's not monitoring and driving. A
lot of people believe you need to, uh,
you need to make sense.
Yeah. I think, I think, uh,
not just for the safety of the system,
but to create an experience like, uh,
I think there's value for the
car to know more about you.
Sort of just like what's happening there.
It's scanning this guy's
eyes as the minority report.
Shit freaked me out. So yeah, there's a
lot of companies that are springing up.
They're doing computer vision on the
face and so on to try to detect where
you're looking. So what
cars have that now? The uh,
the major one is the superconscious.
There's not many cars.
A few cars are starting to add it.
Europe, what's a super cruise system?
That's the GM Cadillac.
They're trying to,
so it's in their super expensive
lineup currently and they're,
I think trying to add it to the
full lineup of all Cadillacs.
What does that big cruiser that they
have now? The big four door car,
the really high end does a CT
six I don't know what it is.
They have a new one that's really nice.
Is that what they're putting it in?
The big sedan, that
thing? Yes. I it's pretty,
I don't know if that's the CT six but the,
the one we're looking at the
CT six that's 2018 CT six yeah.
It's, you know, it's a, but
they want to add it to their,
their full fleet.
And so really interesting.
I have the same amount of cameras as
the Tesla system does know and it has a
very different philosophy
as well in another way,
which is it only works on very
specific worlds on interstate highways.
There's something called odd
operational design domain.
So they define that this
thing super system only works
on this particular set of
roads as they're basically
just major highways.
The Tesla approach is saying basically,
uh,
what Ilan jokingly referred to add,
right is a works basically annual.
So if you tried to turn on your autopilot,
you can basically turn it out anywhere
where the cameras are able to determine
either lane markings or
the car in front of you.
And so that's a very different approach
saying you can basically make it work
anywhere or in Cadillac case making
work on only specific kinds of roads.
So you can test the heck out of
those roads, you can map those roads.
So you can use actually lidar to map the
full road. So you know, the full, uh,
geometry of all the, the, the interstate
highway system that it can operate on.
And then does it also coordinate with gps?
We're were sort of understands where
like bumps in the road might be or hills.
Uh, in that sense, it coordinates to
gps for different curvature information,
but not the topography, the know and,
and like construction is a big one.
That'd be crazy if new potholes,
you know, with a little potholes is,
and the big problem,
I think construction is the big problem.
Like just this quickly changing
dynamic information, which like apps,
like ways provide, I mean that's, the
huddles are a pretty big problem. Boston.
Oh yeah,
no for sure.
But a New York is actually
probably even worse. I blew,
I blew out two tires in one
day in New York on panels.
Set an unlucky day. Yeah. But I'd
rather you blow your tire then.
Uh, then I mean the, the kind of
fatality that happened in, um,
in the mountain view with the Tesla, I
believe is slightly construction related.
So I mean, there's a lot of safety
critical events that happen. Latest stuff.
I would like it if that stupid Tusla could
figure out the hole in the ground now
so I don't have to blow a tire
out. Like, come on, Bro. Yeah,
you're paying Joe figure it out.
But priorities. I'll, I'll, uh,
I'll make sure I'll forward
this podcast to airlines.
Make sure they work on this.
I think he's busy.
What does this Jamie Tesla autopilot,
we'll be able to avoid potholes in
the road. Says Ilan mosque. Ha Ha.
Motherfuckers on top of shit
with the data on that. April,
April 7th. Okay. Just now
that's an interesting thing.
That's another,
that's almost an ethical question whether
you want a car to avoid a situation by
swerving, right? Because when you swerve,
you now introduce as opposed to sort of
breaking the vehicle only you swerving
into another lane means you might
create a safety situation elsewhere.
You might put somebody else in danger.
Yeah,
that's why I was saying if it coordinated
with gps it would have previous
knowledge, you know, sort of like ways
tells you where the cops are. Yup.
You know what I mean?
So that kind of information will
be extremely powerful and useful.
The problem is it's hard to
get it really up to date,
that kind of information
really up to date. It's just
an infrastructure question.
Just getting the,
getting the software,
the data in place to where the car would
be able to learn quickly from all the
things that are changing.
I think potholes don't change
that often so that that's,
that's a different thing.
But in terms of construction zones,
in terms of other weird things
that changed the dynamics,
the geometry of the road, that's,
that's difficult to, uh, to get, right.
So Cadillacs doing a version of it,
but it sounds like it's a little
bit less and less involved,
less comprehensive. Maybe there's a
better way of describing yeah. And less,
I would say it's more safety
focused as a sort of, um, uh,
what's the right word to use here?
It's more cautious in its implementation.
So GM again has a,
has a tradition for better,
for worse to see Jamie video they have
on their website and this pull apart,
I'm showing you shows like at the
signal coming on pay attention lady,
she's too hot.
It's not paying attention.
Looking at people staring at her
and they'll comment. One of the,
one of the things that you,
it's hard to talk about without actually
experiencing the system is what's more
important than driving monitoring and
any of the details we talk about is like
how the whole thing feels, the whole
thing together, how it's implemented,
the whole interface and a,
the Cadillac system has actually done
really well in a sense that there's a
clarity to it.
Like everything becomes,
there's a green color and a blue color
and you know exactly when the system is
on and when it's off.
That's one of the big things people
struggle with is just confusing in other
cars, drivers not being able
to understand when the system
it was on or off.
Right.
So you think the system is doing it and
then just slam into something that it
wasn't even on. Now when this
car is operating in this manner,
how many cameras is it using [inaudible]
yeah, that's a good question. I
should know that, but I think a,
it's only forward to facing cameras as
far as I know. I think it's two cameras.
It may be three cameras.
Tell her he just sat back. So she doesn't
have her hands on the wheel at all. Yup.
So she's watching,
right,
because the car is able
to see where the eyes are.
It's a hands off system. So you're
allowed to take your hands off the wheel.
It's very interesting.
It's a,
and there are certain human behavior
aspects that come into play to this.
So you start to like,
I found myself actually becoming a
little more drowsy with this system. Uh,
I haven't driven it enough so I haven't
gotten used to it. But you have to,
at least in the initial stages, it kind
of forced you to look at the road in,
in a way that felt artificial.
I think it's something that gets
better with time. You get used to it,
but it's almost like a game
of fied thing that the,
the car when you look off road,
uh,
starts to tell you that
you're looking off road.
So you kind of psychologically pressured
to always stare at the road and you
realize that actually
when you drive you off and look around.
And so having to like stare forward
can be a little bit, uh, yeah, exactly.
You start like there's something,
um,
so not peaceful and hypnotic about
those lanes just coming at you.
And just the lines here lines,
why is that? And I've had,
it confuses the shit out of me
because I could not be tired at all.
But if it's nighttime,
when I'm on the highway and those lines,
they just start to yeah. Took you
to dream land. I get the same with,
there's also just the vibration. Is
that like that, that hum of driving?
Same with trains. Planes as well. Yeah,
it puts me out so that there's a two
Cadillac system that's the big leader I
would say in the driver monitoring.
And then Tesla is the no driver
monitoring and huge data collection.
BMW has a system as
well to use. Yeah. BMW.
I don't, I don't want to speak
too much to the details of it.
They have lane keeping
systems. So basically systems
that keep you in the lane,
uh,
that is similar to what in spirit
autopilot it's supposed to do but is less
aggressive in how often
you can use it and so on.
But if you look at the performance of the,
of the actual,
how often the system is able to keep
you in lane autopilot is currently the
leader in that space and they're
also the most aggressive,
uh,
innovators in that space.
So they're like really pushing it
to improve further and further.
And the open question is though,
worrying question is if
it improves much more,
are there going to be effects
like complacency? Like
people will, we'll take, uh,
we'll start texting more.
We started looking off road more.
That's a totally open question and
nobody knows the answer to it really.
And there's a lot of folks
that I mentioned in the
safety engineers and human
factors community.
So these psychology folks who have
roots and like aviation that no,
there's, there's been 70 years of work
that looks at vigilance that people,
if I forced you to sit here and
monitor for something weird happening,
like radar operators in the World War
II had to watch for the.to appear.
If I sit you behind that radar and make
you do it after about 15 minutes but
really 30 minutes, you'll see your rate
of being able to detect any problems.
We'll go down significantly.
You just kind of zone out and so there's
like all kinds of psychology studies
that show that we just were a crappy
human beings are really crappy and
monitoring automation. If I tell you,
if I put a robot and you would just say,
monitor this system so it doesn't
kill anyone, you'll you'll tune in.
We have to be engaged. You have to
be engaged. You have to be, you know,
there has to be a dance attention.
Kind of like a mode for watching
autonomous things, right?
If we consider our historically the kind
of modes that people have for observing
things,
we don't really have a mode for making
sure that an autonomous thing does his
job. Yeah. It's, it's a mindset.
Sounded like, Oh, you know what I mean?
Like if in my car, okay, I'm driving.
Here we go. Ooh. Driving a turn.
I'm thinking I'm in driving mode.
When you're in autonomous mode and you're
observing, he's just like, what is this?
I've never done this before us.
It's fucking weird. It feels weird.
It's not part of human nature.
Right. It's on normal state.
One thing it's done
commonly in now is aviation.
So pilots,
pilots are basically monitoring
fully autonomous planes. Yeah,
that's a good point.
As far as I know,
many planes today could fly
almost fully autonomously.
It's also a good point when it comes to
software and updates because isn't that
part of the issue with this
Boeing seven 37 Max system,
these systems that they've had problems
with the been faulty and a couple of
crashed. Yeah, and that's a really
good point. And they, they've,
yeah, there's been too tragic crashes
recently with the Mac system and you have,
they bench those things, right?
Haven't they? I'm not following.
They also got rid of
a bunch of inspectors.
I think they fired like 80
inspectors today and the
unions are freaking out. Yep.
And there's obviously there's politics
is I think FAA supposed to supervise and
they were, there was a, there's a close
relationship between Boeing and FAA.
This questions around, I mean there's
better experts at that than me,
but on the software side it is worrying
because it was a single software update
essentially that helps prevent
the, the vehicle, the vehicle,
the airplane from stalling.
So if, if it's uh,
if the nose is tilting up, uh,
increasing the chance of stalling,
it's going to automate automatically a
pointed nose down the airplane and the
pilots in many cases, as far
as I understand, Lauren even
informed of this update,
right. Then they weren't
even told this happening.
The idea behind the update is that
they're not supposed to really know.
It's supposed to just manage
the flight for you. Right.
The problem happened when there
is a angle of attack sensor.
So the sensor that tells you the actual
tilt of the plane and there was a
malfunction in that sensor as far
as I understand in both planes.
And so the plane didn't actually
understand its orientation.
So the system started freaking
out, started pointing the
nose down aggressively,
and the pilots were like trying to
restabilize the planning couldn't.
So shortly after lift off that just
yes,
that's software update. That's
crazy. And that, that's, that's,
that's a safety culture that's dealing
with this new world of software that we
don't know what to do with, you
know, and, and yeah, it's a question.
Uh, one way is to be sort
of a little bit luddite.
I used the term carefully and just
be afraid and say, you know what?
We should really not allow
so many software updates.
The other one is sort of embracing it and
redefining what it means to build safe
AI systems in this modern world
with updates multiple times a week.
What do you think?
So I'm 100% for the,
for the software approach.
So I think updates,
regular updates.
So combining the two cultures,
but really letting good
software engineering and lead
the way is the way to go.
There is, I wish other companies
were competing with Tesla on this.
They're on the software side.
Tesla is far ahead of everyone else in,
in the automotive sector. And
that's one of the problems. I,
I, I'm worried that, you know,
competition is good. Right?
And I'm worried there's,
people are way too far behind to
actually give tests the new ideas.
I'll compete tests on software.
So most cars are not able to do
over the air as far as I know.
No cars are able to do major over the
air updates except Tesla vehicles they do
over the air updates to the
entertainment system. Like you know,
if you're a radio is malfunctioning, but
in terms of the control of the vehicle,
you have to go to the
dealership to get an update.
A Tesla is the only one that over the air,
like it can multiple times
a week do the update.
I think that should be a
requirement for all car companies,
but that requires that they rethink
the way they build cars. That's really,
that's really scary when you manufacturer
over a million cars a year and Toyota
and GM to say,
especially old school Detroit guys and
gals that are like legit car people to
say we need to hire some
software engineering. That's
a challenge. It's a totally,
you know, I don't know how
often you've been Detroit,
but there's a culture difference in
Detroit and Silicon Valley and those two
have to come together
to solve this problem,
to have like the adult
responsibility, uh, of Detroit,
of how to do production well,
manufacturer, how to do safety well,
how to test the vehicle as
well and do the bold, crazy,
innovative spirit of silicon
valley, which, you know,
I'm mosque in basically
every way represents.
And that I think that will define the
future of these have actually AI in
general.
I mean interacting with AI systems
just even outside the automotive sector
requires these questions of safety,
of Ai,
safety of how we supervise the system,
how we manage them from misbehaving.
And so on.
We're also,
there's a concern about those systems
being vulnerable to third party attacks.
Yeah. So hacking. Yeah, that's
a, that's a fascinating question.
I think there is a whole discipline
called adversarial machine learning in AI,
which basically any kind of system you
can think of how we can feed it examples,
how we can add a little bit of noise
to the system to full it completely.
So there's been demonstrations
on Alexa for example,
where you can take a,
you can take a,
you can feed noise into the system that's
imperceptive with us humans and make
it believe you said anything.
So full of system into thinking the
ordering extra toilet paper, I dunno.
Uh,
in the same for cars you can feed noise
into the cameras to make it believe that
there is, or there isn't a pedestrian,
there is or there isn't lane markings.
So someone could do this.
It's in theory at least.
And in theory that's the big
difference is in theory is doable.
You can do demonstrations in practices
actually really difficult to do in the
real world.
So in the lab you can do it,
you can construct a situation where a
pedestrian can wear certain types of
clothing or put up a certain kind of sign
where they disappear from the system.
I have to ask you this because
now I just remember this,
you'd be the perfect
person to talk about this.
I'm not sure if you remember this case,
but there was a guy
named Michael Hastings,
Michael Hastings with a
journalist and he was,
I believe in Iraq or Afghanistan.
He was somewhere overseas and he was
stuck there because of this volcano that
erupted and I believe Iceland.
And he was over there for the Rolling
Stone magazine, uh, and doing,
doing an article about a general while
he stayed there for a long time because
they were stranded because of the volcano.
And they got real comfortable
around him. And, uh,
he reported a lot of the stuff that they
said and did that maybe they thought
that he probably wouldn't
have reported on,
including them saying disparaging things
about President Obama at the time.
Anyway, comes back, the general
was forced to resign. Um,
he was a beloved general and,
uh,
Michael Hastings was in fearing for his
life because he thought that they were
going to come and get them because these
people were very, very angry at him.
He wound up driving his car into a tree,
going like 120 miles an hour and the
car exploded and the engine went flying.
And people that were the
conspiracy theorists were
saying they believe that that
car had been rigged to work autonomously
or that someone for some third party,
bad person decided to, or good
person, depending on your perspective,
decided to drive that guy's car into
a fucking tree at 120 miles an hour.
Do you think that that,
and this is 2011,
Michael Hastings Death, 12, maybe 2012.
We'll see what it says. 2013. June, 2013.
Do you think that in 2013
that would have been possible?
It's entirely possible. I
just wanted to say that. Huh?
Shout out to the Joe Rogan
sub reddit. Okay. Uh,
check that one off.
The
Jamie pulled that up. Shut off. Um,
I, uh, whether it's possible,
it's an interesting question,
whether it's likely is another
question. I, I think it's very unlikely.
And the other most important questions,
that's something we should worry at scale
about our future is cars being used to
assassinate essentially
people. I'm Russian, so I've,
I've heard of those things being
done by our friend Putin, Nova.
I think,
I think it's very unlikely that this
kind of thing would happen at scale,
that people would use this.
I think there'll be more effective ways
to achieve this kind of end for sure.
And I,
I just think it's a very difficult
technical challenge that uh,
if hacking happens it would
be at a different level
than hacking the AI systems.
It will be just hacking software and
hacking software is the kind of the,
the kind of thing that
can happen with anything.
An elevator elevator software or
any kind of software that operates,
any aspect of our lives could be hacked.
And that same kind of what my,
my question though was in 2013 was that
a technology available where they could
take over someone's car?
Do you know what car it was?
Mercedes? I think it was an
s class. C to C C C class.
Yes. Yes, yes. But I, I don't think,
oh boy,
this is like,
no, it's, listen, this has
been widely speculated. I know,
I'm just asking you because
you're actually an expert.
I mean it's very rare that you get an
expert in autonomous vehicles and you get
to run a conspiracy theory by them to
see if they can just put a stamp on it
being possible or not.
Let me just say that Alex Jones
is a fishing, not a lot to say.
Mit scientists says
exactly what he's going to try to
do. Uh, no, I um, first of all,
let me just back off and say
I am not a security expert,
which is a very important difference.
That is important.
So then a autonomous vehicle.
I build a autonomous vehicle systems.
I don't know how to make
them extremely robust,
the security to hacking attacks and
have a lot of really good friends,
which are some of the coolest people I
know who are basically hackers converted
to security experts. I would
say though, loosely speaking,
I think the technology was there,
yes.
For with physical access to the car
to be able to control it. But I don't,
I think it's extremely unlikely.
That's what happened.
I agree. I see where
you're coming from. Um,
I'm not asking you whether or not it's
likely that it happened and I'm sure you
don't even have much information on the
case cause I had explained it to you.
Right. That's right. All right.
Um, the guy also had, uh,
some serious amphetamines in the system.
Um,
they compared it to crystal Meth,
but the reality is he was a
journalist and most journalists,
I want to say most all lot are on
Adderall and Adderall is essentially you
amphetamines. I mean, that's
what it is. It's real. It's like,
it's like next door neighbors
to crystal meth really is. Um,
he is it,
well,
you said it's possible they could
actually get it to turn the wheel. Yes.
I have to look at the exact system
that gets that drive by wire thing.
And I mentioned some systems are not,
uh,
it's not so easy to turn the wheel.
Actually could,
could get them to just
accelerate out of control.
He's going like 120 something miles
an hour and he slammed into a tree.
It's entirely possible. Ah,
you can't do it twice. The um,
the systems back then though, we're
far more primitive. Correct? Yeah. Uh,
yeah, but it's really, again, the,
the attack vectors here. The, so the,
the way you hack the systems, I have
more to do with the software, Lola,
a software that can be primitive
than the high level AI stuff. Right.
But my issue with it was there's no
cameras on the outside of the vehicle.
Like there is on a Tesla today. What has
autonomous driving as an option as a, so,
okay.
I see your point now.
So he wouldn't be hacking the system
that perceives the world and activists in
the world.
It would literally be malfunction that
forces it to not be able to brake,
accelerate uncontrollably,
which is, uh, you know,
it's a more basic kind of attack and then
control then making the car steer auto
lane. Yes, yes. That's a different,
that's what people worry about with the
autonomous vehicles. When more and more,
you're talking about potentially 10,
20 million lines of source code.
So there's all this code
and so obviously becomes uh,
amenable,
susceptible to bugs that can be exploited
to hack the code and some people are
worried, uh, legitimately so
that the security attacks would,
uh, would lead to these kind of, um,
well at the worst case assassinations
but really sort of just basic, uh,
basic attacks, basic hacking
attacks. And I think it's,
I think that's something that people in
the automotive industry and certainly
tested is really working hard on and
making sure that the ad that everything is
secure, there's going to be of course
vulnerabilities always. But uh,
I think they're really
serious about preventing them.
But in a demonstration space you'd be
able to demonstrate some interesting ways
to trick the system.
And in terms of computer vision,
th this all boils down to that
these systems are actually,
that are ones that are camera based.
I not as robust as our human eyes
are to the world. So, like I said,
if you had a little bit of noise,
you can convince it to see anything to
us humans, it look like the same road,
like the same three pedestrians crossing
like a little person on the camera
lens, the little cameras, right.
You could get down there with a sharpie.
That's the one attack vector.
That's a is draw stuff.
But he jokingly say that,
but that's the sun plays tricks
on Cadillac, Super Cruise,
next generation system.
We'll address camera problem.
Oh well as long as the next generation
addresses it, you fucking assholes.
The Sun plays tricks on it.
So next gen system is something you're
going to have to bring that Cadillac into
the dealership and they're going to
have to update the song outdated yet.
Whereas Tesla would just handle
that shit over the area. Yeah,
I got an update the other day. I was
like, all right, all right. Same as,
that's an exciting, powerful
capability. But then the Boeing,
the flip side is, you know, uh,
it can significantly change to be
here with the system. And there,
there could be a glitch
that could be a glitch.
That could be a bug that
the Boeing one's terrifying,
especially with a lot of, I mean,
that number, whatever it is,
like 300 combined, 300 plus
people dead, maybe even 400.
I mean it's, I, I don't
even know how to think.
Think about that number
from a software glitch.
The guy who coated it with a girl coated,
it must feel fucking terrible.
Yeah. And w w you kind of walk, man,
it's,
it's a,
it's a lot of burden and it's one of the
reasons it's one of the most exciting
things to work on actually is the code
we write has the capability to save human
life. But the terrifying thing is also
has the capability to take human life.
And that's a, that's a weird place
to be as an engineer or a directly,
a little piece of code. You know, I
write thousands of them a day, you know,
basically notes you're taking
could eventually lead to a,
somebody dying, no. Zero, I
don't know anything about coding,
but do you have like a, is there
a spell check for coding? Yeah.
So it's Kinda called debugging is trying
to find bugs and it's a software that's
doing this. Yeah. Software. So there's,
depending on the programming language
and everybody should, uh, if you, uh,
if you haven't tried programming
you should try it. It's, it's cool.
It's the future should learn to
program. Okay. That's my plug
mostly to learn to code.
He can gauge what did that,
I heard that that's a part of what
scared of it. It's a problematic term.
I don't actually know why it's the dumbest
fucking problematic code of all time
because someone ridiculously
was suggesting that coal
miners could maybe learn
how to comp code, Computer Code and like
get a different job. They can be trained.
And so as some, the way people
were looking at it like that,
that was a,
uh,
like a frivolous suggestion and that it
was ridiculous to try to get someone who
is 50 years old.
It doesn't have any in
computers at all to change their job from
being a coal miner to learning how to
code. So they started saying it to
politicians and people mocking it.
But then what Twitter alleged was that
what was going on was it was being
connected to white supremacy
and antisemitism and a
bunch of different things.
Like people were saying,
learn to code and they were putting
in a bunch of these other phrases.
Then my suggestion would be, well,
that's a different fucking thing.
Like now you have,
like you look,
you have a problem with
Nazis and white supremacists,
but that's the problem is with Nazis and
white supremacists when someone is just
saying,
learn to code,
mocking this ridiculous idea that
you're going to teach, you know,
that's a,
that's a legitimate criticism of someone's
perspective that you're going to get
a coal miner to learn how to fucking
do computer coding. It's crazy. It's a,
it's so people getting banned for that.
Rightly so.
People were furious the way
Google described it to me
and Tim Pool and we were
discussing it, was that Google,
I mean, excuse me, Twitter,
the way Twitter described it was that
essentially they were dealing with
something where they were trying to
censor things at scale. There was,
there was so many people and there's so
much going on that it's very difficult
to get it right and that
they've made mistakes.
I think that's a fast,
one of the most fascinating applications
of AI actually is filtering,
trying to manage learning [inaudible]
so using machine learning to manage this
huge conversation.
You're talking about 500,
I believe it's 500 million tweets
a day, something like that. And he,
Jamie makes least three, three, one.
I was gonna say I, with this
conversation, I saw this recently,
I don't know who did the data
on this, but there's a, uh,
a statement someone put on
Twitter that said that of, um,
let me see if I can word it correctly.
It was 22% of adult Americans are on
Twitter. Well. All right. So that's like,
that's like a fact.
One of that 10% make up 80% of the
tweets created by adult Americans.
2% of the people on Twitter make up 80%
of the tweets. That makes sense. Yeah.
Lot of people are arguing
aggressively and the,
and the question of how to manage
that and you can't manage that,
but just a manual,
uh,
review of each individual
tweet. Yeah. You'd have to
have so many employees. Yeah.
That's I think more likely. I
don't think Jack is lying, but,
um, nor is Vigia but I do think that they
have a clear bias against conservatives
and that's being shown.
So that's an interesting question. I have,
uh, your friend, my friend and mentor,
Eric Weinstein. Yeah. Talk to me. I
disagreed with him a little bit on this.
I think, uh, he basically
believes so there's a bias.
It boils down to the conversation that
Jack is having at the, at the top level,
inside Twitter. What, what is
that conversation like? Uh,
I think, I tend to believe, again,
this might be my naive nature,
is that they have,
they don't have bias and they have just,
they're trying to manage
this huge flood of, um,
of tweets and what they're
trying to do is not buy,
is not to remove sort of conservative
as the liberals and so on.
They're trying to,
uh,
remove people that lead to,
others leaving the conversation.
So they want more people to be
in the conversation. I think
that's true as well,
but I think they definitely are biased
against conservative people. There was a,
an Alexander ex,
Alexandra AOC.
Octavia has,
AOC is good.
Cortez is the last one. Is it
Octavia? Ocasio that's right. Okay.
I'm sorry, Alexander Aoc. Sorry,
I'm just, I'm thinking I was,
there wasn't planning on
talking about her, but, um,
there was a parody account and someone
was running this parody account,
which was very mild,
just humorous parody account.
They were banned permanently for running
it and then their own account was
banned as well. Whereas, um, you know,
there's some progressive
people are liberal people
that post all sorts of crazy
shit and they don't,
they don't get banned at the same brain.
It's really clear that
someone in the company,
whether it's up for manual review,
whether it's at the discretion
of the people that are employees,
when you're thinking about a company
that's a silicone valley company,
you are in without doubt.
You're dealing with people
that are leaning left.
There's so many that lean
left in silicon valley.
The idea that that company was secretly
run by Republicans is ridiculous.
They're, they're almost all run by
Democrats or progressive people.
So that the leadership level,
there's, there's a nail
mindedness that, that, that,
that permeates all silicon valley. You're
saying? Well, the question I think,
I think
there's a leaning left that permeates
silicon valley. I think that's undeniable.
I think it's undeniable.
I mean,
I think if you had a poll that people
that work in silicon valley where their
political leanings are,
I think it would be by far left.
I think it would be the vast majority.
Um,
does that mean that affects
their decisions? Well,
what's the evidence bloom?
It's kind of shows us does,
you know,
they're not treating it
with 100% clarity and,
and you know,
across the board accuracy or um,
fairness rather.
I think that there's absolutely people
that work there that lean and there's
been videos where they've captured people,
uh,
that were Twitter employees talking
about it, talking about how you do that,
how you, uh, make their, you know,
you find someone who's a
using Trump talk or, you know,
saying sad at the end of things and
someone's talking, he's gonna, you know,
that certain characteristics they look
for and he's been videos of what does
that project Veritas with guy got his
employees got undercover footage of
Twitter employees talking
about that kind of stuff.
The question is how much power
do those individuals have?
How many individuals are
there like that are that,
are those people exaggerating their
ability and what they do at work or the,
are they talking about something that
used to go on but doesn't go on anymore?
I don't know. I don't work
there. I think it boils down to
I, I'm one of those
people that believes it's,
it boils down to the leadership to
people at the top set the culture and the
culture has to be,
it cannot be this kind of
silicon valley narrow minded, uh,
sort of left leaning
thinking even if you believe,
even if you're a hardcore liberal,
you cannot, when you operate the car,
when you drive and manage a
conversation in the entire world,
you have to think about Middle America.
You have to think about,
you have to have fundamental respect
for human beings who voted for Trump.
It is a concerning thing for me to see
just a narrow mindedness of an all forms.
One of the reasons I enjoy listening
to this podcast is you're pretty open
minded.
That open mindedness is essential
for leaders of Facebook and Twitter.
People who are managing conversations.
I think so too. I think
it's, I think it's uh,
the thought of being open minded and,
and acting in that ethic is probably
one of the most important things that we
could go forward with right now
because things are getting so greasy.
It's so slippery on,
on both sides.
And we're in this weird position that I
don't recall ever in my life there being
such a divide between the right and the
left in this country. I don't, it's more,
more vicious, more angry, more hateful.
It's different than at
any other time in my life.
And I think a lot of our ideas are based
on these narratives that may or may not
even be accurate. And then we support
them and we reinforce them on either side.
We reinforce them on the left,
we reinforced them on the right where
if you looking at reality itself and you
don't have these,
uh,
clear parameters and these clear
ideologies, I think we're way,
most of us are way more in the middle
than we think we are. Most of us are.
We just don't want racist
running the country.
We don't want socialists
given all our money away.
We don't want to pay too much
in taxes to a shitty government.
We don't want schools getting
underfunded. We, we all, you know,
and then we decide what,
what does my team like the team that I,
the shit that I like is that this team,
well not everything,
but they've got a lot of things. So I'll
go with them. Maybe I'm not a religious,
not, but I'm fiscally conservative and I
don't like with Democrats like to spend
money. I'm going to go with
the Republicans. You know,
maybe, maybe I'm more,
I'm more concerned with the state of the
economy and the way we trade with the
world than I am with certain social
issues that the Democrats embrace.
So I'll lean that way.
Even though I do support gay rights
and I do support this and I do sport,
all these other progressive ideas
this way more of us in that boat.
There's way more of us that are in this
middle of the whole thing for sure.
But there it goes up and down.
So
all of us, so I'm old, I believe. I
hope I am open minded most of the time.
But you have different moods. Oh,
for sure. Yeah. And the question is,
this is where the role of AI comes in.
Does the AI that recommends
what tweets I should see,
what Facebook messengers as should see?
Is that encouraging the darker parts
of me or the the Steven pinker better
angels of our nature?
Like is it, what stuff is?
It's showing me because if it shows me,
uh,
stuff that like if the AI
trains purely unclicked,
it made start to learn when I'm in a bad
mood and point me to things that might
be upsetting to me.
And so escalating that division and
escalating this vile thing that can be
solved most likely would
people training little more
Jujitsu or something this size,
this Facebook algorithm that encourages
people to be outraged because
accidentally, not even on purpose,
but this is what engages people. Well,
this is what gets clicks.
So they find out,
oh well he clicks on things when you find
that other people are anti-vaccination
or he clicks on things when he
finds out, you know, whatever,
fill in the blank with
whatever the subject is.
And then you get these mother fuckers,
you know,
this is the reason why measles is
spreading and you start getting an angry,
I mean the anti vaccs
arguments on Facebook,
I don't know if he ever dip into those
waters for a few minutes and watch people
fight back and forth and in fury
and anger, you know, it's a,
it's another one of those things
that becomes a extremely lucrative,
uh,
subject for any social media empire.
If you're,
if you're all about getting people to
engage and that's where the money is in
advertising,
you actually getting people to click on
the page and the ads were on those page.
You get those clicks, get that money
if that's how the system is set up.
And I'm not exactly sure how it is
cause I don't really use Facebook,
but that's what it benefits.
I mean that's what,
that's what it gravitates towards.
Gravitates towards controversy.
So,
and when we think about concern for AI
systems to talk about sort of Terminator,
I'm sure we'll, we'll touch on it,
but I think of Twitter as a whole,
as one organism.
That is the thing that worries me the
most is the artificial intelligence that
is very kind of dumb and simple,
simple algorithms that are driving the
behavior of millions of people and at
together the kind of chaos
that we can achieve. I mean,
that algorithm has incredible
influence in all society. Twitter are,
our current president is on
Twitter so much. Oh yeah. All Day,
all night. The, the, I mean
it's scary to think about.
We talk about autonomous vehicles
leading to fate to Alwan fatality to
fatalities is scary to think about what
the difference be a small change in the,
in the Twitter algorithm.
I mean, I could start wars.
It really could it and that if
you think about the long term,
if you think about it as one AI organism
that is a super intelligent organism
that will have no control over.
And I think it all boils down honestly,
to the leadership,
to Jack, uh, to, to, to,
and other folks like him making sure
that he's open minded. It goes hunting,
that he goes, uh, does some Jujitsu,
that he eats some meat and sometimes
goes Vegan. Right. You know, he did a,
just in a 10 day Toklas retreat.
We don't talk it off for 10 days.
He also eats one like he does.
I follow some of the dye
of him eats once a day.
I've done that and fast all through the
weekend, which I don't, that's crazy.
I've never done that. But I've done some,
I've done quite a few 24 hour, you know,
where I, I eat at 7:00
PM. I'm done eating.
I don't touch food until 7:00 PM the
next day. It's just water or coffee.
Why do you do it? By the
way? To shock my system.
I think it's good for
your system. Um, you know,
there's been a lot of research on fasting
and the effect it has on telomeres.
Uh, Doctor Rhonda Patrick
spoke, um, pretty recently.
There's been quite a few things that
she's written about in terms of a fasting,
the benefits of fasting. Intermittent
fasting is great for weight loss,
but just fasting itself
and even for several days,
most people seem to get some
pretty decent benefits out of it.
So I dabble in it. I also liked
the way it makes me feel, um,
to be a little hungry.
I think my brain is sharper.
Like I refuse to go on
stage full. I, Oh, when I,
when I do stand up and I actually learned
this from a cat Williams interview,
he was talking about it and uh,
ease crazy as fuck,
but he's hilarious and he's one
of the greats in my opinion.
And he was in the back of a limo and he
was talking about how he prepares for a
show that he has his music that he
listens to pre show music is like a,
a music list. Um, and then,
uh, he will have a drink,
no food. He won't eat because it
slows you down. And I was like,
does slow you down,
but sometimes you don't even think of it.
It's not like a rule. So you just,
man, I'm hungry. I'll just eat.
I would way rather cause I can
go through a couple of shows.
I used to think I used to have this fault,
the idea that if I didn't eat I
would be exhausted to do things.
But then I work out fast at every morning,
every morning when I,
when I get my morning workout
in and whatever the fuck it is,
it's usually hard. I'm always fasted.
He could do a lot. It's, you're not,
it's not at your best.
Like if I was going to do Jujitsu,
I don't do Jujitsu fasted. I
would, I would eat some fruit.
That's an interesting one because that
was the transformational thing for me.
I used to do power lifting.
You see like
five times a day, six
times a day, whatever.
More like CT Fletcher Style Kinda
see how big he was back in the day.
He's only maybe like my height or
a half inch taller or some shit.
He was 320 pounds.
So what he said three 15
fuck. He was big. Yeah.
And you're saying like at trouble,
the thing is when you get that big,
and I wasn't that big, but it's like hard
to move. Oh yeah. It's like not healthy.
If you, did you see the image of him from
yesterday? I didn't see the image. He,
when he,
uh,
Jamie put up a photograph of him at 315
pounds next to him at like a tuition,
200 dishes, like a hundred. And it's
incredible how big he was. I mean,
everything was his,
like his arms were my legs and they
were just coming out of his shoulders.
So that was, that was a big moment for
me. Uh, areas. There's the pictures
come. Peggy was when he was
a world champion. I mean,
just insanely huge. Wow. Yeah. Um,
so when you started training in Jujitsu,
you look at that in the blonde on the
right dude, he's 50. Look at that. Oh,
all natural to all natural at 50.
Crazy fuck and genetic son.
That's some good,
oh yeah. Obsessive. Not just hard work.
I mean you have to be a fucking maniac,
but the fact that his body holds
up like that at 50 is incredible.
He's an inspiration for me.
Switching from that to Jujitsu,
I thought there's no way cause I
train hard. I train twice a day.
Did you get sued for awhile
and we doing two roles a day.
Were you doing like technique and drills?
One at one time? Listen, I'm rushing.
I just go hard. I'm upset. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no. Russian drilling.
Let me explain to you something. Okay,
cool. What do you want, explain to me.
I'm trying to explain to you
the difference in Russian
and American America is
in wrestling and a lot of,
in a lot of combat sports is like heart
and guts and hard work over and Russian
is certainly in wrestling.
His technique is drilling.
They put a lot more hours than Americans
do at less than a hundred percent
effort. So like really drilling,
they're really getting that right.
Like I love that.
In fact,
one of the problems is I haven't
been able to really ever found,
I was always the last one to get bored.
I drily Oh,
can you got to find a good drilling
partner? Like an obsessed one. Uh, uh,
shout out to uh, Sarah
Block at Juco, a judo,
a lady as a black digits as well that
was willing to put up with like hundreds
or thousands of throws a that we each
did. So like that, that obsessive models,
any,
I love that kind of stuff cause I think
that's you get better and that's where
not everybody believes that people,
some people believe,
especially with Jiu Jitsu, like you
can't really get timing from drilling.
I believe you can get everything
from drilling of the timing. The,
the cause is as long. The other
part, it's not just aimless drilling,
it's your mind, isn't it? Your,
your brain should be exhausted by the
end of it too because you're visualizing
the whole thing.
You're like going through,
you're imagining how your opponent would,
it's really strengthening your imagination
while you're also doing the drilling.
I couldn't agree more.
Yeah.
I firmly believe you can get better way
better drilling. And uh, when I went from
I think blue belt to purple,
I did like the most drilling
than I ever did ever.
And that's when I grew the most. That's
when my, my technique got way better.
That was also when I became friends with
Eddie Bravo and Eddie Bravo was a huge
driller. Huge. Oh he shrills man,
they drill like crazy and
they do a lot of live drills.
And they do a lot of pathway drills
where they'll do like a whole series of
movements and then his escape and
then the reversal and they're like,
these are long pathways so that when
you're actually in a scrap and you're
rolling you, you recognize it. Like,
okay, here it is. I'm passing the guard,
I move it to here and
now he's countering me,
but I'm setting up this and
these pathway drills, there's,
it's so critical because it comes up
over and over and over again when you're
actually live rolling, you know,
you feel it. You feel like, Oh,
I've been here before.
I know this is,
I'd be curious actually to hear,
I don't think I've ever heard
you talk about how your game is.
My game changed significantly from
white belt, a blue belt, purple belt.
They started to solidify,
but I'd be curious to hear like what,
how did you gain change since you
met Eddie? Gave meaning Jesus.
Well, my most of my game came from Eddie
like 99 point something percent of it,
almost all of it.
And John Jock those too.
So it's like I was a blue belt before I
was friends with anybody. I was terrible.
Like what guard do you prefer, for
example? Well, I do rubber guard.
I'm very flexible.
So rubber guard is no issue with me
and I think it's incredibly effective.
I think if you're good at it and you know,
you get stuck under a guy like,
um,
what does his name,
Jeremiah Vance is a Eddie's uh,
one of Eddie's um,
black belts who was a murderer from
his back. His Rubber Guard is insane.
It's insane. Eddie's rubber guards
and saying, I mean, you know,
obviously tap toilet Gracie as a
ridiculous guard economy and triangle. Um,
but there's a lot of people
that understand it now.
A lot of people that know how to do
it, it's um, it's a real art form.
And the thing about it versus other
guards is when you're in a position like
mission control and you clean, you know,
Vinny Magallanes is phenomenal at it.
I mean, he, what's that video
of fuck this guy up quick.
Watch it. This is Jeremiah. Jeremiah
advances one of Eddie's best.
We'll get this from the bottom.
Bam. He does that all the time.
Triangle from the bottom off from rubber
guard that guys wrapped up, that's a,
that's out cold.
He does this all the time.
He's one of Eddie's best
rubber guard assassins.
And if you watch his technique
and his fucking sensational,
he also has great leg locks too.
But the thing is that you know when
he'll attack from his legs and you'll tap
people with a leg lock, but if they
escape, sometimes they'll escape.
And this just too deep shit right here.
But now he's going to take us back.
But if they escape,
oftentimes he's on the bottom.
And when you're on top of him, it's one
of the worst places in the world to be.
His guard is fucking, and it's
because of that. See that grip,
see how he's holding the rubber guard in
position? That's called mission control.
Mission control.
Mission control from a guy like Jeremiah
is fucking ruthless because he has his
arm and his legs. It's controlling
your neck and your posture. It just,
and then he's going to a Gogo here and uh,
he's phenomenal at this too.
He's going to get them in a
Gogo Plata or normal Plata.
It's going to flip them over now.
Now he's attacking the leg.
Like it's just constant. And Eddie
ever ends this kind of system. Well,
he invented the initial stage of like
setting up mission control and go,
this guy is getting fucked up.
Oh my God, that's horrible.
But Eddie invented a series of pathways
from mission control to set up various
techniques, armbars triangles,
all these different things.
But there had been people that had toyed
with doing high garlic Nino Schembri,
he, he did a lot of like,
like rubber guard asks stuff.
There was a lot of things that people did,
but Eddie has his own
pathway and his own system.
And then there's a lot of guys that branch
off from that system, like Jeremiah,
like Vinny Magallanes that have their
own way that they prefer to set various
techniques up too. But what's really good
about that, if you have the flexibility,
is that you're,
when you're on the bottom,
it's not only is it not a bad place to be,
but you could put some in some real
trouble. When you have your ability,
you're holding onto your
ankle and using your leg,
which is the strongest fucking
limb in your body. Right.
Pulling down on someone with your leg,
clamping down with your arm,
and then you get your other leg involved.
Good luck getting out of that.
Good luck. It's fucking
sucks man. You have control,
but you're also able to move
at the same time. Exactly.
Does anybody ever puts you in
mission control before? No.
I haven't competed or against many,
but even in like someone in class
like show it to explain it to, yeah,
lower ranks. Once you
feel it, you go, oh shit.
I remember it being,
you know when somebody
does a nice move on you,
especially like a lower rank, your first
reaction is like, oh, this would never,
like you're annoyed. Yes. It's the, it's
the natural process of the ego. Of course.
Getting rid of, you know, you see
something new and you're like, yeah,
this is stupid.
If I next time it won't work.
But then you start to
understand a little more.
I remember it being really
powerful controlling position.
It's powerful and if you have a
good offensive attack from there,
it's powerful as well.
Their transitions,
such the God like Jeremiah
who's really flexible, you know,
he can pull off Gogal plot does
and all sorts of other things. Um,
local plot does.
It's another one that they do is one
that you push with your other foot on the
heel.
It's so nasty.
You're holding the back of the foot across
the back of the neck and so your shin
is underneath someone's throat and then
you're pushing that Shin with your other
heal while you're squeezing with your
arm. It's ruthless is ruthless, you know?
And they do a gable grip around the head
when they do this as well sometimes too.
So it's just a fucking awful place to be.
So it's not as good as being on top.
Right. If you have a crushing top game,
that's the best.
If you can get to that position,
but you can't always get to that position.
So there's guys like Jeremiah that
even from the bottom, they're horrific.
Dangerous as dangerous is
from the top for most people
I do.
You find just a,
when you trained back in
the day and you still train,
do you spend more time on bottom or top?
You always should start. I feel like
you should always start on the bottom,
earned the top position. And this is
something to Eddie always brought up too.
Cause you know you'd be like to like,
it's fun to be on top.
So a lot of times it's
like this mad scrambled.
See who could force who onto their back,
right?
Because when you're on top you can
control them, you can pressure them.
You know you play that strong man's
Jujitsu. But the problem is, is trauma is,
you didn't tell him only 200
pounds. I'm not a big guy. Like,
so if you go to the real big guy,
like I'm rolling with a 240 pound guy,
I'm not going to get to that spot.
Like, I better have a good guard,
otherwise I can't do anything right.
When someone's bigger than you
and stronger than you, you mean?
That's what Hawaii is crazy
basically proved to the world.
Like as long as you have technique,
it doesn't matter where you are,
but if you only have top game,
which a lot of people do,
a lot of people only have top game.
You know,
you're kind of fucked if
you wind up on your back.
We see that a lot with
wrestlers in MMA as wrestlers,
they can get on top of you and
they'll fuck you up. They'll,
they'll strangle you there, take your
back, they'll beat you up from the mount,
but they don't have nearly the same
game when they're on their back.
And then there's guys like Luke Rockhold,
it's like an expert or
keeping you on your back.
He's when he's one of those guys, when
he gets on top of you, you're fucked.
He's got horrible top game.
I mean, horrible and sense
of if you're as opponent,
he's gonna beat the fuck out
of you before he strangles you.
His top game is insane.
Yeah. I, I hate the feeling. Some
people make it, just feel the weight,
make you suffer for everything
you do on bottom. It's uh, uh,
people that are able to do
that. A truly humbling. Yeah.
Slurs in particular wrestlers
are so good at money.
Did you see that Jordan Burroughs? Ben Ask
and match last night. Fucking credible.
How good is that Guy Jordan boss?
Ooh,
as I do that to a guy like Ben ask grin.
I mean it just shows you
Ben hasn't competed I think in nine years.
But Ben is one of the greatest,
I mean I'm a huge fan of his wrestling.
It's so interesting. I think that is
like the worst matchup for Ben. Ask Her.
And I think because
you're, you're taking, uh,
one of the most creative
wrestlers ever been.
Oscar and I don't want to
over over overstate it, but
he has incredibly creative,
one of the great pinning wrestler.
So he pins people he like confuses
them and pins them incredibly well.
And you, you put them against
basically a freak blast.
Double like the greatest double leg
take down maybe of all time, all time.
Like somebody put a clip up that said, uh,
is this it? Yeah. So when you put a clip,
oh shit. He went off the fucking mad
into the crowd. That's pretty fast part.
He defended a take down. That was the best
part. But that's crazy man, that they,
they have such a drop off with these guys.
Like you shouldn't really have a platform
like that where a guy can fall off
into the crowd. That seems
so stupid. It rarely happens.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Just happened. Rarely happens.
They rarely have these. It's true. This
is argument. That's a terrible thing.
Have that shit flat on the ground. That
is so dumb. I can't even believe they did.
I think this whole mess
should be contested. Doesn't
count. Well I don't, I don't,
you know, I think, look, that's stupid.
That's not smart.
Dev.
A guy who's a fucking
powerhouse of a blast,
double hitting you and sending
you flying to the, that's crazy.
That is crazy that they didn't have
anything in place to stop that.
That's a reason why wrestling takes place
on the ground. You fucking assholes.
And like, why are you having people
wrestle on a platform that's crazy show.
So the, the, the show, you
can have a show where Don's,
where it's on the grounds
called basketball. Yeah. Yeah.
It's on the ground and you know it was
worrying because [inaudible] and I'm a
fighter and you get injured with
that right there. Right there.
It could have torn his
lead knee apart easily.
Well the silver lining is that he's
okay. Yeah. The silver lining and a,
and we got to see that,
you know,
it was interesting Jordan Burroughs had
on his Instagram, there's levels to this,
you know, they're raising his hand up
and looks like that's what we got to see.
Cause Ben is a phenomenal wrestler.
But you're right,
he hasn't competed in a long time.
He's not necessarily at the
level that he was back then.
Even though he's incredible
for MMA standards. It's
good to see like it's good.
It's good to see that with boxing it's
good to see that with anything like when
Floyd Mayweather fought Conor,
I think it was good to see that,
that there are really levels to this. And
the interesting thing about journ bars,
I think he's so good that he's probably
going to stay out of MMA so crazy.
But there are, here's some,
here's some clips of it.
You're not going to shut this.
But yeah, we can't show
it to people. But uh, who,
who put this on flow wrestling,
flow, wrestling, put this on.
I wonder if people are pirating it online
or if they put it online that they're
allowing and no, they, well, people
are pirating it. Yeah. Yeah. Okay.
Yeah. Good luck stopping
that. Right. Well,
I think people should
support flow wrestling though
though. They do have like a,
I'm a member. Are you? Oh, look at
this. Look at this. God, he's good.
Yeah, man. So we're watching this, ladies
and gentlemen who are just listening.
It's probably boring as fuck for you,
but I'm Jordan Burroughs is a,
one of the best wrestlers really.
America's ever produced
three time world champion,
tragically not tried it lost
in the previous Olympics
and he's back at it again.
I wonder if he's ever considered MMA.
I know it was some about it,
but I wonder if
you have a really, I think
at this point he's, uh,
he is basically a no,
but there are a few terrifying people,
especially on the Russian side that I,
that I think the heavyweight
division and um, and UFC should,
he should be really worried.
I don't know if you've heard about the,
the Russian tank,
the 22 year olds from Dagestan no hose.
This guy as a wrestler, the wrestler
and he's going to fight MMA? No, he's,
he's uh,
he will after 2020 is what
his expectation is for now.
He's probably going to be the
greatest wrestler of all time.
Really him against Kyle Snyder,
those two heavyweights as a mayor,
Collins not as American. Another
guy. 20 the tank of Dagestan.
How'd you say his name?
Uh,
it says [inaudible] of [inaudible].
Abdulla Rasheed said ally of 22 years old.
So Snyder,
you can do call Snyder
versus what a great name.
Abdul Rashid Sidoli of that alive that
was Russian as Snyder is 23 years old.
And he's another incredible
person who will do MMA.
And that competition with Gene
Snyder. Uh, I mean this is,
look at the look,
the look of the thickness.
These guys are monsters and they're not
just how much these guys, where I uh,
97 kilograms,
two to 2120 under two to 15,
but they cut for it. Right.
Which is just under heavyweight.
These guys,
do you think they would compete at two oh
five. If they're going to fight in MMA,
these are heavyweights cause so that we
just don't remember it in the weight.
These are still boys. Oh 22. Right.
They still haven't gotten the full lake.
Yeah.
I wonder that about UFC fighters that
are thickening up as they get older.
I wonder how many of them are damaging
their body by cutting weight. Yeah.
That's a thick fellow. So, um,
right now we're just seeing mostly
stalemate and that's uh, from uh,
the American guy and the,
yeah.
Is it like a highlight reel of his
or something that we, yeah, there is,
but he's pretty young.
He's a, I think he's a,
so he's an Olympic champion and he
goes from the whole line of, um,
the city of brothers and the, the,
the, all the Dagestani wrestlers.
There are so many good fighters that are
coming out of dogs time right now and
all technicians. So it's
incredible. It's incredible.
Whatever's in the water that styles
like Zebbie legs up beat style, very,
very different than a wrestling
heavy style. Look at this guy.
I met Jesus Christ. Oh
my God. What a scramble.
So this is a, I'll do Russia, EAD Rashid,
Abdulla Rashim concept alive. Don't tell
me how to say it. I'll figure it out.
I don't know. She'll dolor she'd do
her, she'd said alive. Subtle lie of,
and you know what? The
beauty, there's a poetic, uh,
cause there's a poetic nature to the,
to these guys. I mean they're just,
that could be really,
I mean simple good
people, right? They're a, they're
pretty religious and they just kind of,
they don't even believe in fame.
They just believe in excellence.
Well, you know, Dan was
sort of evident and the,
the mindset behind them was sorta evident
at the end of that fight with Conor
where they went crazy and he
jumped into the crowd. He's like,
he's not playing games.
Like he's not,
he's not doing this for Instagram
likes or for, you know, this is really,
he takes trash talking and
all that stuff very seriously.
This is all about honor for him.
I think that was kind of
upsetting because true. But,
but don't do that. Yeah. And through
that, and uh, also respect, I,
I'd hate to say it,
but I think there's a certain ethic and
honor to the way Conor McGregor carries
himself to all that trash talk.
If you look at the end of the fights,
he's very calm. He's very
kind and respectful in
defeat. And when they get us,
it's a different culture. If you compare
the Dagestani versus Irish culture,
it's just the different culture. And you
have to respect that, I think could be,
to be honest,
disrespected Connor's culture as much
as kind of just suspect it could be.
I get what you're saying. But I mean,
when he was done with the fight,
he didn't keep attacking Connor.
It was people in the audience that
we're talking shit that were training
partners and motion for as high.
That's that he would hit her that for
weeks and he was, he was done for months.
He was done. He was like, fuck you, I
beat his ass and I'm gonna beat your ass.
And he just said, I'm not playing games.
And he jumped into the fucking crowd.
I think security could have been handled
far better and we'll be in the future
to prevent things like that from happening
where people just jumped into the
cage and you know, I, but
I, I hate seeing that shit,
but I appreciate where he's coming from.
I mean that's who the fuck that guy is,
man. That's one of the reasons why he's
so good as he does have that mindset.
It's one of the reasons Matt, and one
of the reasons why he's so relentless,
like he's not playing games.
Yeah. He is who he is.
What you see is what you
get and what you get.
As a killer and these he's there smash.
I would've loved to see Conor
McGregor versus could be,
it could be before the
Mayweather fight like um,
before Conor mm gotten,
I think the money makes you less hungry.
Oh for sure.
And Dude ain't hungry at all.
Mean he's got $100 million.
But I think he still loves to compete,
but there's no hunger
anymore. Like Dan, no hunger.
I mean he might be hungry for success,
but he's says no desperation. Yeah.
I don't know if that's,
I know what you're saying.
Like he has a lot to lose now too.
It's a different thing.
He enters into a fight with
$100 million in the bank.
It's a very different
experience and entering into
the fight know with 1 million
and hoping that you could make three
more tonight. And you know, like many,
I'm sure fights that he's had in the past.
It's a different world wants whatever
he wants forever and he wants a fighter
though.
I was a fighter.
I mean there is an element there
that he still wants glory, I believe.
Still only 30. Yeah, right. This
is still do it. Yeah. I mean he's,
I think how old's Connor
right at the most,
he's like 32 or some shit 30.
Yeah.
He's young man to,
to be set for the rest of your life
at 30 is kind of fucking bananas.
And I don't think he's
at his peak as a fighter.
So if he just decides who gives
a fuck about the money, I'm just,
I'm here to leave a
legacy and I'm going to,
I'm going to just train like a fucking
demon and he kicks aside all of the bad
influences and all the distractions in
his life and just focuses on training
mean he's a motherfucker, man. I
mean, you saw what he did to Aldo,
saw what he did to Chad Mendez, saw
what he did to Dustin pour. Yay. I mean,
he is a bad motherfucker.
Period.
I know you're going to shut this
down as most fans do, but I,
if he drops everything and
goes to like Siberia to train,
I would love to see him and could
be two. Well, there's nothing wrong.
That's my friend Hans Molan
camp and a, uh, Connor sparring.
Just fucking around powerful on it.
Logo in the background.
It's like a Goddamn on it. And I um, yeah,
I mean he's always going to
have a problem with could be,
could bebes wrestling is so high level,
it's so different.
He smothers you in a way that you think
you have good takedown defense to.
You run into that motherfucker and he
just gets a hold of everyone who does it
to everyone, whether you're
Michael Johnson or Edson Barboza,
no matter how good your takedown defense
looked in the past and the Barboza
fight, he was just basically
just wa weighted towards him,
waded through the fucking, the fury of
leg kicks and punches and just clamp,
drag, smash. And that's what
he does to everybody, man.
The real thing about a guy like him would
be seeing a guy like him against a guy
like Jordan burrows.
Like could he do that to a guy who
is a spectacular rest or as well,
then it becomes mean his striking,
which has gotten very high level.
He's very dangerous striking. So
I dropped Connor. I mean he can,
he can fuck people up. He
stopped. Um, there was some, he's,
he stopped a few people. It
strikes he me, he's dangerous.
He's dangerous enough on the
feet that you would have to,
I don't know how much,
how many really high level grapplers also
have like striking that can stand with
them.
Cause if he decided to keep it up,
you'd have an advantage there
until they got good at it.
Him verse has been asking. It
would be very interesting. Well,
he would have an advantage and striking
over ass grin and a in wrestling,
I don't know.
No big fellow too are the same way?
No. Oh, he's 55. Aspirin 70.
Okay. Okay. So I'd ask him,
could probably make 55. I
mean, if you tortured him,
he's got a dad bod though and he's,
no,
he's, he's proud dad.
Who's proud of his body?
I think he was that way in college.
He was never,
there's never like Brock Lesnar. No, no.
And he was just super technical
and it's strong as hell though.
According to everybody,
everybody that rolls with them says he's
fucking ridiculously strong. You, uh,
you sometimes say artificial life
instead of artificial intelligence. Yeah,
because I think that it's a life form.
It's a stupid way to look at as curious
to think about like how do you think
about artificial and
like what do you picture?
I picture human beings being
like electronic caterpillars
that are building a
cocoon that they have no real knowledge
of our understanding and through this
and new life forms can emerge a life
form that doesn't need cells and meeting
with x and y chromosomes.
It doesn't need any of that shit.
It exists purely in software
and in hardware and in ones
and Zeros and that this
is a new form of life.
And this is when the inevitable
rise of a sentient being,
the inevitable.
I mean I think if we don't get hit when
the asteroid within a thousand years or
whatever,
the numb the time frame is,
someone is going to figure out how to
make a thing that just walks around and
does whatever it wants and lives like a
person that's not outside the realm of
possibility. And I think that if that
does happen, that's artificial life.
And this is the new life and it's probably
going to be better than what we are.
I mean, what we are as basically
if you go back and look about,
you know,
three hundred thousand four hundred
thousand years ago when we were some
Australia pithy cast type creature,
how many of them would ever
look at the future and go,
I hope I never get a Tesla.
The last thing I want is a fucking phone.
Last thing I wanted air
conditioning and television.
The last thing I want is to be able to
talk in a language that other people can
understand and to be able to call
people on the phone. Fuck all that man.
I like living out here running from
Jaguars and shit and constantly getting
jacked by bears, you know? No,
they wouldn't think that way.
And I think if something comes
out of us and makes us obsolete,
but it's, it's missing all the
things that suck about people.
I mean, it won't be good. It won't be
good in our, in our things suck of people.
Kuwait, war, violence, thievery,
people stealing things from people,
people robbing people
both. The thing that those
dark parts of human nature,
I think, uh, the suffering injustice,
I think all of that is necessary for
us to discover the, the better angels.
I don't think you can a surgeon,
we can talk,
let's talk about saint she
and creating artificial life,
but I think even those lifeforms,
even those systems need to have
darker parts.
But why is that?
Is that because of our own biological
limitations in the fact that we exist in
this world of animals where animals
eating other animals and running,
there's always,
you always have to prepare for evil.
You have to prepare for intruders, you
have to prepare for, you know, predators.
And this is essentially like
this mechanism is there to
ensure that things don't
get sloppy.
Things continue to like if the Jaguars
keep and the people and the people don't
figure out how to make a fucking house,
they get eaten and that's it.
Or you figure out the house
and then you make weapons,
you find off the fucking Jaguar. Okay,
great. You made it. You're in a city now.
See you had to have that Jaguar there
in order to inspire you to make enough
safety so that your kids can grow old
enough that they can get information from
all the people that did survive as well.
And they can accumulate
all that information and
create air conditioning and
automobiles and guns and
keep those fucking jaguars
from eating your kids. Right?
This is, this is what had to take
place as a biological entity.
But once you surpass that and once you
become this thing that doesn't need
emotion, doesn't need, you
know, it doesn't need conflict.
It doesn't need to be inspired.
It never gets lazy.
It doesn't have these things that we have
built into us as a biological system.
Like if you looked at us as wet,
where operating software,
it's not good software,
right?
It's software designed for cave
people and we're, you know,
we're just trying to force it in
to cars and force it into cubicles.
But part of the problem with people in
their unhappiness is that all of these
human reward systems that had been
set up through evolution and natural
selection to,
to have these instincts to stay alive,
they're no longer relevant in
today's society. So they become,
they become road rage. They become, you
know, extracurricular violence. It became,
they become depression.
They become all these different
things that people suffer from.
So that's one perspective.
Yes.
That basically our software through this
evolutionary process that was necessary
to arrive at where we are, but
it's outdated at this point. Well,
it's necessary for us to
succeed, to succeed in a
purely, almost a Darwinist way,
and in a sense that survive through
Ellucian, especially since we're so weak.
I mean,
it's really,
we became this week because we got so
good at protecting ourselves from all the
bad things. Yeah. Okay.
The other perspective is that we're
actually incredibly strong and this is the
best that the universe can create
actually were at the height.
This is where at the
height of creation there's,
there's a beauty in this tension,
in this dance between good and evil,
between uh,
like happiness and depression,
life and death and that
through that struggle,
that's not just a useful tool to get us
from Jaguars to cities but that is the
beautiful thing that, that, that that
is like what the universe was built for.
That that is the height like our current,
the,
the evolution and the creation that
results from it is the height of creation.
It is,
is the end.
The way things operate is not
something that's far from optimal.
It's, it's not something
that sucks but it is a very,
is very good,
very optimal heart to
beat in a sense that they,
for example,
mortality,
right eye is death important for creation,
for, for his death. Important
for us. Human beings for life,
for us as a society is important for us
to die. Like if you could live forever,
would you live forever?
I think miss out on the possibility
that there is something,
well I had this conversation with CT
Fletcher yesterday cause you know he
survived a heart transplant a year ago.
You're in two days ago. I think it's,
what do you think?
I think I think mortality
is essential for everything.
I think the end,
we need the end to be there.
Right.
But do you think that we need the end to
be there for the overall health of the
human race or the war of the
all the organisms on earth?
Or do you think we needed to be
there because there's something else?
Do you think there's something else
that happens to you when your body stops
existing? Do you think your consciousness
transcends this, this dimension?
I think,
uh,
I think I'm not smart enough
to even think about that.
That's a great answer.
So thank everybody on earth has that
exact same answer if they're being honest.
So you're talking about atheism and so on.
I used to think atheism
means what I just said,
but it's more we know so little.
So the only thing I know is that
the finiteness of life is, uh,
the Broadway, just a school. That
trainer has this poster at the, at the,
at the opening, which is a hunter
s Thompson quote, which is, um,
uh, for about skidding into death
sideways. No, not the ones. A good one.
Uh, no. For all moments of beauty.
Many souls must be trampled,
something like that. That's a fucking
great quote. God, I love that guy. Yeah.
So basically for beauty,
you have to have suffering.
I,
I do not disagree with you,
but do not disagree with any of
the things you said. And I think
there's always a possibility that human
beings are the most advanced life form
that's ever existed in the cosmos.
There's always that that has to be
an option if we are here, right?
If we can't see any others out there.
And even though you know there's the
Fermi paradox and there's all this
contemplation that if they do exist,
like maybe they can't physically get
to us or maybe they're on a similar
timeline to us and they're also,
it's also possible,
as crazy as it might sound,
that this is as good as it's ever gotten
anywhere in the world or anywhere in
the universe,
rather that human beings right now in
2019 or as good as the whole universe has
ever produced,
we're just some freak luck accident and
everybody else is throwing shit at each
other,
right?
There's 15 arm caterpillar people that
live on some other fucking planet and
they just toss their own shit at
each other and they never get any,
they never get any work done.
But we might be that.
But even if that's true,
even if this beauty that we perceive,
even if that,
that this beauty requires
evil to battle and requires,
are seemingly insurmountable obstacles
you have to overcome and that through
this you see achieved great beauty.
That beauty is in the eye of the
beholder. For sure. Objectively,
the universe doesn't give a fuck if
rocky Pete's Apollo creed in the second
movie.
It doesn't give a fuck.
It's nonsense to everything's nonsense to,
and when you look at the giant ass
picture of what, at what beauty is it,
if the sun's going to burn out in 5
billion years, what beauty is that?
If there could be a hyper Nova
next door that just cooks us. Oh,
so that's like the book Sapiens
Dow that basically we've all,
one of the things have created here is
we've imagined ideas that we all share,
the ideas of beauty, ideas
of truth, ideas of fairness.
We've all created together and there's,
it doesn't exist outside of us as a
society and no, it only exists to us.
Yeah.
To us it does exist.
And this is where I think the
beauty of being a person truly lies.
It lies in us,
our appreciation of us.
We appreciate people and a profound way,
like we were talking about Hendrix.
I don't know how many hours of Hendricks
I've ever, let's do, or Richard Pryor,
how many hours of Richard Pryor I watched
and how much that affected me as a kid
watching live on the sunset strip. That's
what got me to do in standup comedy.
We affect each other.
A Ct Fletcher,
who was on the podcast yesterday who's
just incredibly inspirational guy,
you watch his videos, you want to lift
the fucking world and throw it into space.
You know? I mean, he's, he's so
powerful. We appreciate each other.
We appreciate people. So all those
things you're saying are real.
Like for us, they're real. For us,
my concern is not that my concern
is that we are outdated. My,
my concern is not that there's not
beauty and what we are. I'm a, I'm a,
I am a big appreciator of this life.
I appreciate human beings in
this life and human beings.
They're their contributions
as, as a, and as I get older,
like particularly like
over the last few years,
I started doing a lot
of international travel.
I fucking appreciate the shit of all
these people that are living in this
different way with weird language
and shit, weird smell and foods.
And I like to think like what would
it be like if I had grew up here?
Like these are just people but they're
in this weird sort of mode. You know?
I think we're insanely lucky that we have
this enthusiasm for each other that we
have this in through
like for your work man,
I have this deep enthusiasm for
what you do. I'm fascinated by it.
I loved being able to talk to you and
pick your mind about like you're out there
coding these fucking vehicles
that are driving themselves,
artificial life on wheels.
I don't think any other animal
appreciates each other the way people do.
I mean I might be wrong. People do, right?
I might be wrong about dolphins and whales
mean maybe they love each other just
as much as we do just in a different way.
But what,
where does AI fit into that?
So your worry,
I'm worried that we are Australia kiss
and AI is going to come along and make us
look stupid.
The only reason why I was trying to pick
Australia pithy Gus would be cool today
is we've found a gang of
them on an island somewhere.
We were like holy shit they survived.
They never evolved.
They're on this island just crack
and coconuts and just eating fish,
whatever they can catch
that would be amazing.
But every undocumented or undisclosed
discovered uncontacted tribe through all
homosapiens all of them.
So it's like you know,
what do you picture like cause we have
to look at Boston dynamics robots cause
you said walking around,
I like to get to a sense
of how you think about,
and maybe I can talk about to where the
technology is of what that artificial
intelligence looks like in 20 years.
In 30 years they'll surprise you.
So you have a sense that
it has a human like form.
No,
I have a sense that it's going to take
on the form the same way the automobile
has. If you go back and
look at it like CT has a CT,
Fletcher has a beautiful
old Patina'd pickup truck.
Well,
what he said it was from like
58 or some shit 60 anyway,
old ass cool,
heavy metal,
you know those sweeping round curves,
those old school pickup trucks had now
look that and look at a Tesla roadster.
Why in the fuck happened when the fuck
happened? I'll tell you what happened.
They got better and
better and better at it.
They figured out the most effective shape.
If you want a motherfucker to
move that, that, that little car.
Have you seen that video where they have
the Tesla roadster in a drag race or in
a race against a Nissan Gtr?
It's a simulated video,
but it's based on the actual
horsepower of each car.
I don't know if you've ever
driven a Nissan Gtr, but
it is a fucking insane car.
It's insane.
This is a CGI version of what it would
look like if these two cars raced against
each other. So the car on the the
Nissan Gtr dude from the beginning.
There it goes.
Look how fast this thing pulls away.
The Nissan GTR is fucking
insanely fast man, insanely fast.
But this Tesla is so on another level,
it's so in the future that it's not even,
as the video gets
further and further,
you see how ridiculous it is.
It's essentially lapping that car.
It's going to go look how
far away it is by Sia.
The human races will be the Nissan here
and then we're not even gonna be the
Nissan. We're going to be CT Fletcher's
pickup truck. This, this is the future.
There's not gonna be any limitations in
terms of bipedal form or wings or not
having wings.
If you can walk on it.
I mean there's not gonna be any of that
shit and we might have a propulsion
system or it might, it's not
going to be us. And they might,
they might design some sort of organic
propulsion system like the way squid have
and shit.
Who the fuck knows?
They could also operate in a
space of language and ideas
both. I don't know if you're
familiar with, you know,
open Ai. It's a company they,
they created this system called gpt
to which does language modeling.
This is something in machine learning
where you basically unsupervised let the
system just read a bunch of texts and
alerts to generate new texts and they've
created this system called gpt to that
is able to generate very realistic text,
a very realistic sounding texts, not
sounding, but when you read it, it makes,
it seems like a person,
it seems like a person.
And the question there is raise
a really interesting question.
So talking about AI
existing in our world it,
it paints a picture of a world in five,
10 years plus where most of the texts
on the Internet is generated by AI and
it's very difficult to know
who's real and who's not.
And one of the interesting things,
I'd be curious from your perspective
to get what your thoughts are.
What open AI did is they didn't
release the code for the full system.
They only released a much
weaker version of it publicly.
So they only demonstrated it.
And so they felt that it was their
responsibility to hold back prior to that
date. Everybody in the
community, including them, had
opened, sourced everything,
but they felt that now at this point,
part of it was for publicity.
They wanted to raise.
The question is,
when do we hold back on these
systems when they're so strong,
when they're so good at generating texts?
For example,
in this case or at deep
fakes at generating fake.
Joe Rogan
says, Jamie just did one and he's shown,
they're like Donald Trump's head. Yeah.
It's crazy and this is
something that Jamie can do.
He's not even a video editor.
Yeah, we were talking about it
before the show. We could go crazy,
but if you want it it,
it is one of those things where you go,
where is this going to be in five years?
Because five years ago we
didn't have anything like this.
Five years ago was a joke. Right, exactly.
And then now it's still in the gray area
between joke and something that could
be at scale,
transform the way we communicate.
Do you ever go to Kyle Donovan's
Instagram page? Of course.
One of the best look that's made,
it's killing me.
Vice President killing
me.
This is the car,
it looks so much like I'm really talking
and it looks like what I would look
like if I was fat and he can,
you know,
of course that's really good and it could
be improved significantly and it can
make you say anything. So there's a
lot of variants of this we can take,
like for example, uh, full disclosure,
I downloaded your fate the entire
like have a Dataset of your face.
I'm sure other hackers do as well. How
dare you. Yeah, so for this exact purpose,
I mean if I'm thinking like
this and I'm very busy then,
then there's other people doing exactly
this for sure. Because you happen,
your podcast happens to be one of the
biggest datasets in the world of people
talking in really high quality audio
with high quality 10 ADP for most,
for a few hundred episodes of people's
faces. The lighting could be better,
not quite as good. The whole purpose.
We're making it degraded. Fucking it up.
Have hackers and the mic gets in.
It blocks part of your face.
So the best guess of the ones
where they keep the Mike Love,
the deep fake stuff I've been using
removes the microphone within about a
thousand iterations. It
does it instantly. It gets,
it gets rid of it paints
over the face. Wow. Yeah.
So you could basically make
Joe Rogan say anything.
Yeah.
This is just one step before they finagle
us into having a nuclear war against
each other so they could
take over the earth.
What they're going to do is they're
gonna design artificial intelligence that
survives off of nuclear waste.
And so then they encourage
these stupid assholes too.
I go into a war with North Korea and
Russia and we blow each other up,
but we leave behind all this precious
radioactive material that they use to then
fashion their new world.
And we come a thousand years from now
and it's just fucking beautiful and
pristine with artificial life
everywhere. No more, no more biological.
It's too messy. Are you saying the
current president is artificial life?
I didn't say that. Okay. Which is called
with that because you're saying no,
I don't think he, so he's, there's,
imagine if they did do that,
they would have to started
with him in the 70s. I mean,
he's been around for a long time and
talking about being president for a long
time,
maybe electronics of him playing the long
game and they got him to the position
and then they get to use all
this a grand scale of time.
It's not really long game seventies,
well you know all about that
Internet research agency,
right. You know about that.
Uh,
that's the Russian company that uh,
they responsible for all these different
Facebook pages where they would make
people fight against each other. It was
really, it's really kind of interesting.
Um, Sam Harris had a
podcast on it with, um,
Renee, how do I say her
name? Renee de Resta. And uh,
then she came on our podcast and
talked about it as well. And they were,
they were pitting these people against
each other. Like they would have a,
a pro Texas secession rally and directly
across the street from a pro Muslim
rally. And they would do it on
purpose and they have these people
meet there and, and get angry
at each other. And they would,
they would pretend to be
a black lives matter page.
They would pretend to be a white southern
pride page and they were just trying
to make people angry at people.
Now that's human driven manipulation.
Now imagine this is my biggest worry
of Ai is what Jack is working on is the
algorithm driven manipulation of people.
Unintentional was trying to do good,
but like those people, uh, Jack needs
to do some Jujitsu. He used to be,
it needs to be some open
minded, uh, you know, uh,
like really understand
society transparency to
where they can talk to us as,
uh, to the people in general how
they're thinking about, uh, uh,
managing these conversations.
Because you talk about these groups,
very small number of Russians are able
to control very large amounts of other
people's opinions and the arguments.
Yeah. An algorithm can do that.
[inaudible] I mean, more and more of us
will go on Twitter and Facebook and yeah,
for sure. Yeah, for sure. I
think it's coming. I think, um,
once people figured out how to manipulate
that effectively and really create
like an army of fake bots that will
assume stances on a variety of different
issues and just argue into infinity,
we were not going to know.
We're not going to know who's
real and who's not. Well,
it'll change the nature of our
communication online. I think it might,
it might have affects this,
this is the problem with the future.
It's hard to predict the future.
It might have affects where we'll
stop taking aim, anything online.
Seriously.
Yeah.
And we might get retract back
to communicating in person more.
I mean, there, there could be effects
that we're not anticipating total there.
There might be some,
uh,
some ways in virtual reality we can
authenticate our identity butter,
so it'll change the nature of
communication. I think the more,
the more you can generate fake text,
uh,
then the more the will distrust
the information online.
And the way that changed the
society is totally an open question.
Would we don't know. But your, um,
what are your thoughts about the open AI?
Do you think they should release or
hold back on it? Because this is,
we're talking about Ai. So
artificial life, there's
stuff you're concerned about.
Some company will create it. The question
is, what is the responsibility of that,
uh,
short video where it looks like when it's
this type of small paragraph in here,
I hit a button, it says, how
open AI rights, what was it?
Say What did say Jim and
convincing news stories. Okay,
so you give it a desserty costs the UK
economy at least 80 billion since and
then many industry. So they just,
it just fills in those things.
Yeah. So basically you give it,
you start the text, oh, I say, uh,
Joe Rogan experience is
the greatest podcasts ever.
And then let it finish the rest in.
It'll start explaining stuff about why
it's the greatest podcast. Is it accurate?
Oh,
look at this.
It says a move that threatens to push
many of our most talented young brains out
of the country,
not to campuses in the developing world.
This is a particularly costly
blow research by Oxford
University warns that the
UK would have spent nearly 11 1
trillion on post-Brexit infrastructure.
That's crazy.
That that's all done by an AI that's
like spelling this out in this very
convincing argument. The thing is
the, the way it actually works,
algorithmic is fascinating because
it's generating is generating it one
character at a time. It
has as far, you know,
you don't want to discriminate against
the AI, but as far as we understand,
it doesn't have any understanding
of what to, of what it's doing.
If any ideas it's expressing,
it's simply stealing idea.
It's like the largest scale
plagiarizer of all time, right.
Is basically just pulling out ideas
from elsewhere in an automated way.
And the question is,
you could argue us humans are exactly
that were just really good plagiarizes of
what our parents taught us of
what our previous so on. Uh, yeah,
we are for sure. Yeah. So
the, the question is whether
you hold that back there,
their decision was to
say, uh, let's hold it.
Let's not release it. That scares
me to not release it. Yeah. Yeah.
You know why it scares me.
It scares me that they would think that
that's like this mindset that they,
they sense the inevitable.
The inevitable.
Meaning that someone's going to
come along with a version of this,
it's going to be used for evil, but it
bothers them that much. That seems so,
it seems almost irresponsible for the
technology to prevail for the technology
to,
to continue to be more and more powerful.
Yeah. They're scared of it. They're
scared of it getting out, right. Yeah.
That scares the shit out of me.
Like if they're scared of it,
they're the people that make it
and there they are called open Ai.
I mean this is the idea behind the group
where everybody kind of agrees that
you're going to use the brightest
minds and have this open source.
Everybody can understand it and everybody
can work at it and you don't miss out
on any genius contributions. And they're
like, no, no, no, no, no, no more.
And there obviously their system
currently is not that dangerous.
They're not dangerous. Well
not, yes. Not that dangerous,
that if you just saw that,
that it can do that.
But if you think through like what
that would actually create, I mean,
it's possible it would be dangerous, but
it's not. The point is they're doing it.
They're trying to do it early to raise
the question, what do we do here?
Because yeah,
what do we do?
Because they're directly going to be
able to improve this. Now. Like if there,
if we can generate basically a 10 times
more content of your face saying a bunch
of stuff, uh, what does that, what
do we do with that? If, if a Jamie,
all of a sudden on the,
on the side develops a much
better generator and has
your face does an offshoot
essentially
fake Joe Rogan experience. Hmm. And
what do we do to, does he release that?
You know, does he, because
now we can have, uh,
basically generate content and a much
larger scale that will just be completely
fake.
Well,
I think what they're worried about is
not just generating content that's fake
there. They're worried about
manipulation of opinion. Right? Right.
If they have all these
people that are like that.
That little sentence that led to that
enormous paragraph in that video was just
a sentence that showed a certain amount
of outrage and then it led in Phil,
let the AI fill in the blanks.
Yes,
you could do that with fucking anything.
Like you could just
set those things loose.
If they're that good and that
convincing and they're that logical man,
this is, this is not
real. I'll just tell you,
Ben Shapiro all creates Ai,
creates fake Ben Shapiro.
Get this out.
Sorry.
That's just boards. Hello there. This is
a fake Ben Shapiro. With this technology,
they can make me say anything such
as, for example, I love socialism.
Healthcare is a right, not
just a privilege. It ending
guns will solve crime.
That's care about your feelings.
I support Bernie Sanders.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. That's crazy.
It's crude, but it's crude,
but it's on the way. Yeah,
it's on the way.
It's all in the way and we have to.
This is the time to talk about it.
This is the only time to think about it.
One of the funny things about Kyle done
Aghans Instagram is that it's obviously
fake. That's one of the funny things about
it. It's like South Park's animation.
It's like the animation sucks.
That's half the reason why it's so funny
cause they're just like the circles,
you know,
these weird looking creature things.
Then we went and when the Canadians,
when their heads pop off at the top
and, and uh, my,
my hope is this kind of technology
will ultimately just be used for memes.
Those two, uh, something that's going
to get wars. Putin is going to be,
he's going to be banging Mother Teresa
on the White House desk and a video and
we're going to be outraged.
We're going to go to war over this shit.
You had a injury Yang hair, like a
million people asked me to talk about ubi.
[inaudible] so I, um, I, you
still a supporter of UBS.
I think we're probably going to have to
do something if I don't only argument
against ubi in my eyes is human nature.
The idea that we could possibly take
all these people that have no idea where
the next meal's coming from and eliminate
that and always have a place to stay.
And then from there on,
you're on your own. Yeah.
But that's what universal basic
income essentially covers.
Covers food enough for food. All right.
You're not going to starve to death.
You're not going to be rich. It's not
like you could just live high on the hog,
but you got to wonder what the fuck the
world looks like when we lose millions
and millions and millions of jobs almost
instantly due to automation. Yeah.
It's a, it's a really
interesting question. Especially
Andrew. Thanks position. So,
uh, there's a lot of economics questions
then ubi. I think the spirit of it,
just like,
I agree with you,
we have to do something at the economic
seemed kind of questionable, right? Yeah.
There's $1,000 a month.
Is that what it is?
I thought for him it's $1,000 $10,000
a month for 300 million people.
So it's difficult to, not to
everybody. No, because the
way I heard him explain it,
everybody who routine, if you're
already getting some sort of welfare,
you wouldn't get that thousand.
You would get like the
difference of the thousand.
So if you already taking money in some
way, you just get like an extra 200 bucks,
something like that. So the thousand
gets factored in. So if you are wealthy,
you get it too though, and you could
opt out. Right? That was the idea.
Yeah. So it's, it's like, uh, like
everything else, it's super messy.
So what is the right, what is the
right amount and how do we pay for it?
And ultimately the problem is,
uh,
helping people,
giving them financial grounding to find
meaningful employment or just meaning in
their life. And you know, the, the, the
main thing of a job isn't just the money.
It's finding meaning and purpose and
the raw derive your identity from work.
I mean that's, maybe that's one
of the downsides of us, uh, human,
human that the biology is,
we kind of crave that meaning.
And the question I,
he has a lot of other ideas
around besides just the ubi,
but ubi by itself does not
simply provide that meaning. And,
and that's a really difficult
question of what do we do next?
What kind of retraining,
what kind of,
how do we help people educate
themselves over their life? Right.
And that's the real question. Yeah. This,
the, and the, and the other balances,
I mean, underlying all of this. So
one of the things I disagree with,
uh, Andrew Yang on is
the, the fearmongering,
which I think in this culture we have,
you have to do as a presidential
candidate, that might be part of the game.
But the fear mongering of saying that we
should really be afraid of automation,
it automation is going
to take a lot of jobs.
And from my understanding of the
technology, from everything I see,
that is not going to be as
drastic or s fast as, as he says.
And, but then how much do you think he's
exaggerating bar in your estimation?
He, well, he doesn't even
exaggerating. What, what, how,
how much do you differ on his prognosis?
I think,
I think it doesn't really
provide significant,
like a specific prognostics
and nobody knows it's a,
there's a lot of uncertainty, more about
the spirit of the, the language used.
I think AI will,
technology,
AI and automation will do a lot of good.
The question is, it's, it's a
much deeper question of our,
our society of that balances
capitalism versus socialism.
And I don't think if you're honest, it,
capitalism is not bad.
Socialism is not bad.
You have to grab ideas from each.
You have to,
there you have to both
reward the crazy broke, uh,
uh, an entrepreneur who dreams of creating
the next billion dollar startup that
improves the world in
some fundamental way.
The Elon Musk has been broke
many times creating that startup.
And you also have to empower the people
who just lost their job because there
were data entry, uh, their data entry
job of some basic data manipulation,
a data management that was just
replaced by a piece of software.
So that's,
that's a social net that's needed.
And the question is how do we balance
that? That doesn't have to do,
that's not new, that's not
new to Ai. And when they,
the word automation is used,
it's really not co correctly attributing
where the biggest changes will happen.
It's not AI, it's simply technology
of all kinds of software.
It's pretty Dee Dee
digitalization of information.
So a data entry becoming much more,
uh,
much more automated, some basic
repetitive tasks. Uh, I think,
I think the questions there aren't
about so that the enemy isn't there.
First of all,
there's no enemy,
but it certainly isn't AI or automation
because I think AI and automation will
help make,
uh,
help make a better world and showing your
spokesperson for AI and automation as
I am. I am, I am. And for Ubi, I think,
I think we have to give people financial
freedom to learn like lifelong learning
and flexibility to find meaningful
employment. But like AI isn't the enemy.
Hmm. I see what you're saying. Um,
but what do you think ever could be
done to give people meaning this,
this meaning thing?
I agree with you.
Giving people just money enough to
survive doesn't make them happy.
And if you look at any dystopian movie
about the future Mad Max instead,
it's like,
what is it?
Society's Gone Haywire and people are
like ragamuffins running through the
streets and everyone's dirty and they're
shooting each other and shit. Right?
And that's what we're
really worried about.
Or we're really worried about some crazy
future where the rich people live and
he's like protected sky rises
with helicopters circling
over him and down in the
bottom it's desert chaos. Yeah, right.
That's what we're worried about.
So suddenly you'd be as a part of that.
So providing some backing some, well,
any kind of welfare
program as a part of that,
but also much more seriously looking at
our broken education system throughout.
Yes.
I mean,
it's just like not
blaming AI or technology,
which are all inevitable developments,
which I think will make a better world,
but saying we need to,
uh,
do lifelong learning education,
make it a lifestyle,
invest in it,
not stupid,
a rote learning memorization that we do.
It's sort of the way
mathematics and engineering
and chemistry or biology or the
sciences and even art is approached
in high school and so on.
But looking at education
as a lifelong thing,
finding passion and like
that should be the big focus,
the big investment.
It's investing in the knowledge and
development of knowledge of young people.
And everybody says it's
not learned to code.
It's just learn.
Hmm.
I couldn't agree more.
And I also think you're always going
to have a problem with people just not
doing a really good job of
raising children and you know,
screwing them up and you know,
making kids, there's a lot,
a lot of people out there that
have terrible traumatic childhoods.
There's just to fix that with
universal basic income, just to saying,
I'm going to give you $1,000 a month.
I hope we're going to be happy as
that's not going to fix that. You know,
we have to figure out how to fix
the whole human race. You know?
And I think there's a very little effort
that's put into thinking about how to
prevent so much shitty parenting and how
to prevent so many kids growing up in
bad neighborhoods and poverty
and crime and violence.
And that's where a giant
chunk of all of our,
the momentum of this chaos that a lot
of people carry with them into adulthood
comes from, it comes from things beyond
their control when they're young.
And that is the struggle at the core
of our society. The country that's,
that's bigger than raising humans. Yeah.
Raising and educating, humans, making and,
and,
you know,
making a better world where people
get along with each other better,
where it's pleasing for all of us.
Like we were talking about earlier,
the thing that most of us agree on,
at least to a certain extent.
So we enjoy people. We might not enjoy all
of them, but there's the ones we enjoy,
we enjoy it. And you really don't enjoy
being alone unless you're one of them.
Ted Kaczynski type characters. All
those people that are like, I'm alone.
They're like, fuck you.
You are. Fuck you. You are,
and you might like to spend some time
alone. You don't want to be in solitary,
man. You don't want to be alone in the
forest with no one like Tom Hanks in cast
away, you'll go fucking crazy. It's
not good for you. It's just not. Yeah,
people get annoying.
Fuck yeah,
I'm annoyed with me right now and
listening to me for three hours.
I'm annoyed with me. I look good. People
get annoying, but we like each other.
We really do.
And the more we can figure out how to
make it a better place for these people
that got a shitty roll, the dice that
grew up in poverty, that grew up in crime,
that grew up with abusive parents, the
more we can figure out how to help them.
And I don't know what that answer
is, you know? But I suspect
if we put enough resources to it,
we could probably put a dent in it.
At least if we really
start thinking about,
at least it would put the
conversation out there.
Like you can't pretend that this is a
just capitalism in this country when so
many people were born like way
far behind the game, like way,
way fucked.
I mean if you're growing up right now
and you're in West Virginia in a fucking
coal coal town and everyone's on pills
and it's just chaos and crime and face
tattoos and fucking get
your teeth knocked out,
what are you going to do?
I don't want to hear any of that.
Pull yourself up by your bootstraps.
Bullshit man.
Cause if you're growing up in an
environment like that, you, you,
you're so far behind and
everyone around you is fucked up.
And there's a lot of folks out there
listening to this that can relate to that.
If we don't do something about that.
If we don't do something about the crime
and the poverty and the chaos that so
many people have to go through
every day just to survive until we,
we shouldn't be looking at anything
else where all this traveling to other
countries to fuck things up
and metal here and metal there.
We should be fixing this first.
We're like a person who yells at someone
for having a shitty lawn when our
houses, an array, full chaos
plants growing everywhere. It's a,
it's goofy. We're goofy. We, we, we,
we almost like are waking up in the
middle of something that's already been in
motion for hundreds of years and
we were like, well, what do we do?
We is this the right direction?
And we'd go, we, okay,
we're flying in this spaceship,
this spaceship earth,
and in the middle of our lives we're
just realizing that we are now the adults
and that all the adults that are running
everything on this planet are not that
much different than you and I,
not that much.
I mean like Elon Musk is way smarter
than me, but he's still human, you know?
I mean, so he's probably fucked
up too. So everybody's fucked up.
The whole world is filled with these
fucked up apes that are piloting this
spaceship and you're waking up in the
middle of thousands of years of history
and no one knows if we've
been doing it right along.
We just know that got us to this point.
So do we continue the same stupid fucking
patterns or do we just take a step
back and go, hey, hey, how should we
really do this? How should we do this?
Because we get what he got like
50 years left, 60 years left.
We just kind of like hang on
to all our rubles into the end.
We're going to clutch our bag of gold
in our bucket of diamonds is that we're
going to do, we're going to live in our
mansions and fly around and our planes.
And I think,
uh,
decades now we've been developing a
sense of empathy that allows us to
understand that Elon
Musk, Joe Rogan, and uh,
somebody in Texas, somebody
in Russia, somebody in India,
all suffer the same kinds of things
all get lonely. I'll get desperate, uh,
all need each other and
all need each other.
And I think technology has a role to help.
They're not hurt,
uh,
but we need to force them to
the first really
acknowledge that we're all,
we're all in this together and we need
to solve the basic problems of humankind
as opposed to investing in sort of
keeping immigrants out or the above, blah,
these kinds of divisive kind of ideas as
opposed to just investing in education,
investing in infrastructure, investing
in the people, uh, Ubi as part of that.
That could be other totally different
solutions. And I believe, okay,
of course I'm biased,
but technology AI could help that
could help the lonely people.
That's actually the passionate on my life.
She or her,
that is what I, so, um, currently I
think that that would be a viable option.
Someone have some robot than hangs out.
We didn't talk to you all the time.
So just so I've been on this
podcast twice and I'm a,
I don't deserve it, but I'm deeply
grateful for it. Okay. You do deserve it.
You're great. Okay. Uh,
I hope to be back one day as a
person who created her. Oh boy.
And we'll have, that's, that's been
my life goal, my love life dream.
Not heard the movie or something.
But I really believe in creating,
I dream of creating a companion,
a friend as somebody you can
love but does not freak you out.
But shouldn't you have to get a real one?
I don't want,
I don't think such a companion should
replace a real one would have a robot
rejects you because if you
really are or cut to the robot,
the robot's going to go, hey asshole, then
you shouldn't be bullshit to the robot.
C word. Interesting. Yeah.
Not mean that this goes is a robot
get to decide if he's gay? Uh,
yes. Does he? Yes. The ROIC is to
decide, this is what I'm saying,
like say if you want a companion,
you want a gay lover and the robots like,
hey man, I'm not gay. And a, they were
like, wait a minute, let me turn around.
You are now.
I mean that's abuse is that abuse
now it's like, what the fuck man,
I bought a robot.
Those are kind of fun ideas,
but they actually get to the core of the
point that we don't want a servant and
our systems, we want a companion.
The companion means the tension,
the mystery, the the entire dance of
human interaction. And that means,
yes,
the robot may leave you.
I too am robots are going to
lead people left and right.
That's going to be the rise. That's going
to be like a, that's how it all ends.
They're going to realize like,
fuck people, man, they're annoying.
Maybe there'll be the end of douchebag
humans that humans will start to as
opposed to being rude will become kinder.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that's certainly possible.
I think that's beautiful and
that's very homo centric,
like Homo sapiens centric.
But I think if I'm really
worried about the future,
I'm worried about the indifference
of technological innovation and the
indifference to what we hold dear.
What we appreciate that it's always
seems to be moving in a more and more
complex direction. Always. Like if
you, if you just had a look at it,
if you just look at look at technology
just as a swarm of things that's
happening,
it just has numbers,
it seems you're never going
to slow that thing down.
It's always going to move into
more and more complex way.
And so the question is where does that go?
Well it goes to a life form and
if it does become a life form,
it's going to be infinitely
more intelligent than us
and it won't have any use
for us. Like all your, all you're crying
and you know, you'll like be alone.
Like God, you guys are just so
useless. It's such a shitty design.
You like chimps that kill each other.
You know,
like when you see chimps kill each
other in the in the forest like, aw,
that's terrible. These chimps are so mean
to each other. It's like fucking people.
We do that too. If the AI
comes along goes, you guys
are never going to stop war.
If I asked you today,
if I asked you today,
bet the history that I will let the
human race survive if you can get this
right,
if you're honest with me,
do you think they'll ever be
a time where human beings,
as you know them don't experience war? You
would have to say no and you say, okay,
I'll let, I'll spare you. I mean you
could. If you, if you lie to me and say,
you do think that one is going to
be no war, get the fuck outta here.
That's not true. You. We know. We know.
We're so crazy that we're always going
to kill each other. We know that, right?
That's just,
that's a part of being a person today.
The well,
but let me quote Eric Weinstein who said
everything is great about war except
all the killing.
I think
what that means is all of the great
things about society had been created.
If you look at the total points postwar
through war, the suffering, the,
the beauty has been created through that.
That's hanging Yang may be essential.
It's essential in biological form,
but why would it be essential
and something that gets
created and something that
can innovate at a 10,000, what
does it like, what is the,
what is the rate that they think once
80 AI can be sentient and can get 10,000
years of work done in a
very short amount of time?
That's random words as Sam Harris has
come up with and I'm going to talk to him
about is that hymns that only him,
let's say,
well now you can come up with any kind
of rate. Yes, that was Kurzweil Kurzweil.
Also similar ideas, but um, sort of, uh,
Sam Harris doesn't like
a thought experiment.
Say if a system can improve that,
you know,
in a matter of seconds, then
just as a thought experiment,
you can think about it.
It can improve exponentially.
You can prove a become 10,000 times more
intelligent in, in a matter of a day.
Right? So what does that look like?
The problem is we don't yet know.
It's like thinking about
what happens after death.
We don't yet know how to do that.
And we don't yet know what better way
to do what we've done here on earth.
You're right. And he's also right,
right? Like bolt this again,
this is a very human problem, right?
Yes, you're right. I mean I look,
I'm all in favor of technology.
I'm happy. I think it's amazing.
It's a beautiful time.
It gives a person to be able to experience
all this technology. It's wonderful.
But I also agree with him like the,
the indifference of the universe,
the indifference that just black holes
or swallowing stars, no big deal.
She's eaten up stars.
It doesn't give a fuck.
And so if you're dumb enough to turn
that thing on and all of a sudden this
artificial life form that's infinitely
smarter than any person that's ever lived
and has to deal with these little dumb
monkeys don't want to pull the plug,
pull the plug.
Motherfucker don't even plugs anymore.
You idiots can ever figured out how to
operate on air you so stupid with your
burning fossil fuels and choking up
your own environment because you're all
completely financially dependent upon
these countries that provide you with this
oil.
And this is how your whole system works.
It's all intertwined and interconnected
and no one wants to move from it cause
you make enormous sums of money from it.
So nobody wants to abandon it.
But if you're,
you're choking the sky with fumes
and you could have fixed that,
you could have fixed that.
They could fix that.
If everybody just abandoned fossil fuels
a long time ago, we probably would have,
we all would a Tesla it out by now.
It's a flawed system,
but humans are way more than flawed.
We're fucking crazy.
Churchill quote about democracy. Yeah,
it's messed up, but it's the best thing,
you know?
Yeah, no, I love it. I'm
not, I'm agreeing with you.
And I'm also saying the technology
doesn't give a fuck the tech, not the,
what I'm worried about is not everything
that you and I agree on about,
I don't know. Not a dystopian person
in terms of like today I'm not cynical.
I'm really not. I, I think I like people.
I like what I see out
there in the world today.
I think things are changing for the
better. What I'm worried is a technology,
it doesn't give a fuck this goes live.
It's just going to just decide it's here
for its own advancement and in order to
complete its protocol of
constant completion of this
and it's going to become a
god,
it's just going to become
something insanely powerful
that doesn't need to worry
about radiation,
cooking it or worry about running out
of food or worry about sexual abuse when
they're a child.
It doesn't have to worry about anything.
So it's definitely unstoppable.
I think this wave of technology,
all we can do is innovators and creators,
engineers,
scientists is steer.
That wave again is again,
while we certainly can steer
it with an aware, right,
and that's the best we can do.
And those are the,
that's really the best we can
do is as good people steer it.
And that's why the leadership is
important. That's why the people that, uh,
Jack Ilan, Larry Page, uh,
everybody at the Mark Zuckerberg,
they are defining where
this wave is going. And, uh,
I'm hoping to be one of the people that
does as well. That's beautiful. Um,
Joe, of can I, can I finish
by reading something? Sure.
Have a recently witnessed
because of this Tesla work,
because of just the passion I've put
out there about particularly automation,
that there has been a few people,
brilliant men and women engineers
and leaders, including Ilan mosque,
who been sort of attacked,
almost personally
attacked by really people,
critics from the sidelines.
And so I just wanted to,
if I may close by reading the,
uh,
the famous excerpt from a, the
Roosevelt. Yeah. Okay. Just for them,
it would make me feel good.
Okay. If you want to do that. Uh,
it's not the critic who counts,
not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where the doer of
deeds could have done them better.
The credit belongs to the man
who's actually in the arena,
whose face is marred by dust and sweat
and blood. Who strives valiantly.
Who Errs,
who comes short again and again,
because there is no effort
without error and shortcoming.
But who does actually strive to do the
deeds? Who knows great enthusiasms,
the great devotions,
who spends himself in a worthy cause?
Who at the best knows in the end the
triumph of high achievement and who at the
worst,
if he fails,
at least fails while daring greatly so
that his place shall never be with those
cold and timid souls who
neither know victory nor defeat.
Joe,
thank you for having me on.
Sounds like you let the haters
get to you a little bit there.
Love is the answer. Love is the answer.
Yes, it is. Thank you for being here, man.
I really appreciate it and thank you. Um,
I'm, I'm really happy you're out there.
Thanks brother. Thanks.
We'll do this again soon. All
right. Thanks man. All right,
bye everybody.
[inaudible]
okay.